[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 19 janvier à la
veille d'un nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire olivier verront promet la
transparence sur les vaccins sous le feu
des critiques des élus qui espéraient
davantage de doses
le ministre de la santé va publier le
nombre précis dont chaque centre dispose
les stations ski elles seront bientôt
fixés sur leur sort peu d'espoir pour
les professionnels de la montagne alors
que la menace du variant britannique
contrarie le calendrier dernière journée
de donald trump à la maison blanche au
moment où son successeur joe biden
arrive à washington et se prépare à
prêter serment dans une haie mais
fragilisée et inquiète
un passage de relais en l'absence du
président sortant et dans une capitale
aux allures de camp retranché
vous venez de me
à la veille d'un nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire olivier vers en visite
au siège de l'agencé régionale de santé
d'île de france
le ministre de la santé a notamment
répondu à la salle de critiques des élus
qui lui reprochait le manque de d'ozoir
leur absence au premier jour de
l'ouverture de la vaccination à plus de
6 millions de français on retrouve notre
reporter david kelly fa en direct depuis
l'elysée un bon soir david une semaine
encore crucial s'annonce donc sur le
front sanitaire que peut-on déjà retenir
de cette journée
et à quoi doit-on s'attendre on la suit
eh bien écoutez stéphanie olivier vers
ans a tenté de rassurer quant aux délais
de vaccination le ministre de la santé a
reconnu et que la campagne élargi aux
plus de 75 ans prendra du temps mais que
l'objectif de vacciner 2,4 millions de
personnes d'ici fin février était
maintenue je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage de certaines d'entre elles en
ce deuxième jour de vaccination élargi
vous allez voir que l'organisation est
toujours pointé du doigt le problème
téléphoniques sont saturées et on peut
prendre rendez-vous que par standard
téléphonique ou par internet
les problèmes que je rencontre depuis la
semaine dernière depuis vendredi que
j'essaie d'avoir un rendez vous que ce
soit sur les trois sites c'est à dire le
39 75 ou sante.fr ou le numéro 0 800 les
trois numéros s'entassaient duration en
permanence et vous renvoie un jour
prochain
impossible mes enfants essayer c'est le
grand bazar je crois ce côté là mon
épouse s'est inscrite
c'était hier matin et
dans le logiciel mme
on pose la question est ce que vous êtes
accompagné de quelques uns donc je suis
son époux elle a voulu m'inscrire
et puis
ben ça ne marchait pas donc
et
je les accompagne et elle est en train
de se faire vacciner et puis moi je sais
pas quand est-ce que
je pourrais revenir il faut que je
recommence donc ces problèmes
informatiques
autre inquiétude le retard de livraison
en cause des soucis de production de
pfizer fabricant de l'un des deux
vaccins a distribué en france jean
castex a avoué que la france ne
recevrait cette semaine que 320 mille
doses au lieu des cinq cent vingt mille
initialement prévu sur un total est de
1,5 1,6 million à deux doses le premier
ministre a promis que ce retard sera
rattrapé affirme que plus d'un million
de français seront vaccinés d'ici à la
fin du mois de janvier
nous sommes évidemment et vous le savez
comme les autres pays dépendant du
nombre de doses qui nous sont livrés
bien entendu et vous avez observé que
cette semaine demain très précisément
alors que nous aurions dû comme les
autres pays européens recevoir cinq cent
vingt cinq mille doses du vaccin pfizer
nous n'en recevront que 320 milles mais
ce sera rattrapé il faut dire la vérité
la vaccination c'est une opération de
masse qui concerne le monde entier
les capacités de production sont à bloc
et la france en profitera au même rythme
que les autres et plusieurs questions se
posent évidemment autour du conseil de
défense qui se tiendra demain d'abord le
danger de la variante britannique ducobu
elle pourrait devenir un dominante en
france entre fin février et mi mars
et ceci pourrait changer la donne
concernant le port du masque puisque
dans un dernier avis le haut conseil de
la santé publique a recommandé à
d'éviter certains masque en tissu a jugé
trop peu efficace contre le coc u19 et
david en annonce on attend des annonces
importantes demain pour la montagne et
ce variant ducobu 19 semblerait avoir
une incidence sur l'éventuelle
réouverture des stations de ski ont
février
effectivement à stéphanie a
malheureusement elle les espoirs sont
bien minces un la situation sanitaire ne
s'améliorant pas les professionnels de
la montagne ne se font pas d'illusions
une remise en marche rapide des
remontées mécaniques serait synonyme
d'une forte reprise d'activité en
février et donc elle d'un passage de
personnes trop importants dans les
stations de ski
inconséquence les membres du
gouvernement ont confirmé à demi mot
qu'il n'y aurait pas de réouverture est
d'ici à février du coup beaucoup se sont
fait une raison à tourner la page de
cette saison noire et tente de trouver à
des alternatives estivale pour sauver ce
qu'ils peuvent
la décision devrait être prise demain
alors du conseil de défense sanitaire
puis officialisée jeudi lors du
traditionnel point presse a désormais un
milicien et meggie suez est déjà maman
est déjà quasiment connu
merci david kelly fin en direct depuis
l'elysée on l'aura compris la crise du
cours d'un virus est imprévisible c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire et la gestion
des masses des tests aujourd'hui des
doses de vaccin n'est pas toujours
optimale
plusieurs enquêtes ont été ouvertes un
décryptage signé cyrielle benavides
bulbul la cour de justice de la
république seule instance habilitée à
juger les membres de l'exécutif pour
l'exercice de leurs fonctions a ouvert
le 7 juillet 2020 une information
judiciaire pour abstention de combattre
un sinistre
cent quarante sept plaintes ont été
déposées
mais seules 14 d'entre elles ont été
jugées recevables
elle vise olivier ferrand agnès buzyn et
edouard philippe
une gestion controversée de l'épidémie
qui s'est traduite par un manque de
masquer l'absence de masques durant la
première vague a mis en danger les
professionnels de santé et les employés
exposés au virus comme les employés de
supermarché comment s'explique ce manque
en 2018 des centaines de milliers de
masques sont périmés ils sont détruits
mais non renouvelé les réserves passe
alors de près de 2 milliards d'unités en
2009 à seulement 100 millions au début
de la crise de 2020 et la communication
changeantes de l'exécutif n'a pas aidé
d'inutiles pour le grand public le
masque est devenu obligatoire partout
quelques mois plus tard l'opposition
évoquant un mensonge d'état
des embouteillages dans les laboratoires
l'institut pasteur a permis à la france
de mettre au point un test rapide ment
début mars le conseil scientifique a
constaté que la france avait une
capacité de 3000 test par semaine alors
que les allemands en effectuer 60 milles
le conseil scientifique était convaincu
que la stratégie des tests était la
bonne mais nous n'avions pas
suffisamment de tests pour la mettre en
oeuvre
post confinement le gouvernement met à
disposition de la population
sept cent mille tests par semaine
problème les laboratoires sont
surchargés et les délais pour obtenir
les résultats trop long par conséquent
le traçage et l'isolément des cas
positifs ne sont pas efficaces
un début de campagne vaccinale raté la
priorité a été donnée sur les conseils
de la haute autorité de santé aux
personnes âgées résidant dans les ehpad
et aux personnels les plus à risque des
maisons de retraite soit la vaccination
d'environ un million de personnes
mais la logistique s'en est mêlé et les
ehpad n'était pas prêt et résultat
quelques piqûres sont effectués le 27
décembre 2020 mais la campagne débute
véritablement la semaine du 11 janvier
lundi soir le ministre de la santé a
annoncé près de 480 mille personnes
vaccinées tandis que nos voisins
allemands et italiens avaient dépassé la
barre du million de personnes ayant reçu
la première injection du vaccin
campagne vaccinale mais aussi les masses
cas on en parle et ils ont été jugés à
nécessaire il fut un temps ce sont
aujourd'hui certains d'entre eux en
tissu qui doivent être mis au rebut face
aux variants alors on tente ivoire cluc
plus clair si c'est possible avec nos
invités place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir nous sommes
avec fabrice di vizio avocats des
professionnels de santé avocat
d'ailleurs de ses nombreuses plaintes
qu'on a vu dans ce sujet bonsoir fabrice
di vizio merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés jacques myard mer et l'air de
maisons laffitte bonsoir à vous aussi
denis jacquet entrepreneurs également
est avec nous merci d'être là avoue
aussi denis jacquet alors olivier
verrons tout d'abord sur le terrain pour
tenter de mettre fin à la fronde des
maires sur l'approvisionnement en
vaccins tous posent la même question les
a entendu longuement toute la journée où
sont les vaccins ils étaient se mettra
notamment au siège de la rs de
seine-saint-denis pour livrer quelques
explications écouter le ministre de la
santé
nous n'avons pas à ce stade mais 6
millions de vaccins nous sommes donc
dans un fonctionnement à flux tendu à
chaque fois que des vaccins nous sont
livrés toutes les semaines immédiatement
ils sont répartis dans les neuf centres
de vaccination dans l'ensemble du
territoire national et donc à mesure que
ces vaccins arrivent nous ouvrons des
créneaux de vaccination alors que dit
l'élu de terrain à maisons-laffitte vous
avez été livrés vous jacques myard
écouter dans les yvelines et dans les
vignes qui sont autour de nous il y a
trois centres qui sont prévus un et déjà
ouverts il s'agit de
saint-germain-en-laye celui de
sartrouville auxquelles nous allons
aller il sera ouvert lundi le 25 et
l'après midi j'ai eu le médecin qui va
s'en charger qui va surveiller les
vaccinations
elle m'a dit je ne suis pas certain
d'avoir les doses dont il ya un vrai
problème de livraison et je crois que
tout ça ça se planifie à l'avance il y
avait un deuxième problème c'est qu'il
faut des gens aussi pour vacciner et là
j'étais un appel
dans la population pour savoir quelles
étaient les médecins les infirmiers fois
à la retraite qui était volontaire et là
bon point
une trentaine de vaccinateurs si je peux
me permettre cette expression se sont
prononcés volontairement pour venir
vacciner donc qu'est-ce que ça signifie
ça signifie que ce soit pour la
livraison des vaccins
que ce soit pour les personnes qui
seront volontaires ça se prépare à
l'avance et là malheureusement on voit
bien que le gouvernement n'a pas su
réellement anticipé la livraison
j'ajoute que lorsque le ministre parle
de 900 centres sur la france c'est un
chiffre théorique à ce qu' ils ne sont
pas tous armés comme on dit notamment
dans un certain nombre d'hôpitaux
donc il y à un manque de préparation
les vaccins vont arriver c'est certain
il est aussi certain que si vous essayez
d'avoir un rendez vous avez quelques
difficultés parce que à mon sens il eût
fallu diviser pour régner et à boire par
région un certain nombre de plates
formes qui permettent d'enregistrer les
demandes
un ami m'a dit qu'un 5h30 du matin il a
parfaitement lu les deux rendez vous /
dr libre et c'était un 5h30 du matin
bon mais tous les français vont se lever
à 3 heures du matin pour essayer prendre
un rendez vous sur d'octo libre
logistique poussive manque de vaccins
une politique un qui a une voix forte à
sonner la charge hier martine aubry
quand c'est flou il y à un loup dit la
maire de lille qui a réclamé la
transparence totale sur la question des
vaccins on réécoute martine aubry la
vérité il faut nous le dire
est-ce qu'on a ces vaccins ou est ce
qu'on n'en a pas assez qu'on le dit aux
français qu'on ne fasse pas comme le
coût du masque d'un fabrice di vizio le
coût du masque vous ne connaissez très
bien et cette demande de vérité ça veut
dire qu'il y aurait mensonge quelle est
votre analyse de la situation sur le
front désormais des vaccins le sage
montre la lune l'idiot regarde le doigt
c'est ça effectivement la position
la position c'est que vous êtes tous
entrain de disserter des questions
logistiques alors qu'à une première
question à se poser c'est est-ce que
vous parlez de vérité mais sur ces
populations âgées en particulier quand
moi j'ai vu les consentements
les formulaires de consentement qui sont
ceux des ehpad à destination des
résidents bas excusez moi mais on est
face à un problème est la question de
savoir si on a assez de vaccins ou pas
elle est absolument pas la question on
s'en fiche
vous avez un problème vous avez les
autorités sanitaires qui vous expliquent
que le vaccin n'a pas fait la
démonstration son efficacité 75 ans pas
moi qui le dit c'est un outil sanitaire
qui le dit et on passe effectivement
vous parlez de vérité mais on pas cette
question complètement vert à côté de la
question sont filles de cette question
c'est pas un problème il faut vacciner
vaccinaux à tour de bras
je me paie donc une question on en a
parlé ici-même notamment le scepticisme
des français dont on parle régulièrement
sur cette antenne il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui le débat effectivement
c'est sur l'organisation parce qu'ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux tout de
même les français vouloir se faire
vacciner fabrice di vizio tout de même
non mais attendez moi j'ai pas de
problème à l'idée qui veut se faire
vacciner simplement vous parlez de
vérité et de transparence j'ai le droit
de m'interroger sur le point de savoir
si cette transparence et cette vérité
elle est complète c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné j'entends çà et là des
médecins vous expliquer qu'il faut aller
plus vite qu'il faut effectivement
revoir les règles du consentement il
faut pas effectivement s'embarrasser
avec le consentement
alors moi je veux bien que vous
discutiez logistique nous pouvons
discuter tant que vous voulez mais moi
ce que je voudrais être ce que voudrait
être sûr en tant qu'avocat des
professions de santé
d'abord c'est que les professionnels de
santé effectivement on arrête de leur
mentir en disant qu'ils sont pas exposés
à un risque lorsqu'ils vaccine parce que
c'est pas vrai et quand effectivement
aux patients qu'ils aient bien la
conscience est bien de ce qu' ils
peuvent se faire vacciner ya aucune
difficulté mais il faut qu'un
consentement soit libre et éclairé quant
au reste seule organisation qu'est ce
que voulez je vous dise
on a une organisation qui est à peu près
aussi nul que celle qu'on a eu au départ
qu'on est celle qu'on a eu au milieu et
celle qu'on a maintenant ça continuera
comme ça jusqu'à la fin
fabrice levis un juste une petite
question parce qu'on est trois dans le
débat justement vous qui êtes au plus
proche des soignants pour ce que vous
êtes l'avocat de beaucoup d'entre eux
comment ça s'est passé pour eux
rapidement à leurs campagnes de
vaccination puisse qu'ils étaient
nombreux
à être supposé être vaccinés parmi les
prioritaires bah en fait pour se poser
zico que moi j'en ai ça a été un petit
peu le bazar parce que les soignants qui
souhaitaient se faire vacciner parce
qu'on est sur la base du volontariat les
soignants qui souhaitaient se vacciner
n'ont pas réussi à pouvoir effectivement
le faire dans un temps raisonnable
il ya eu des couacs assez terrible au
niveau d'organisation en tout cas dans
certains hôpitaux en libéral s'est pas
beaucoup mieux
donc voilà les écoutes moi j'ai eu si
vous voulez en première intention sont
les échos d'une très grande
désorganisation
à l'époque vous donnez jacquet vous
aviez cherché à mettre en place une
filière d'approvisionnement de masse
pour les entreprises parce que
précisément le gouvernement était
absence c'est la même chose aujourd'hui
pour les vaccins on a un sentiment de
désorganisation qu'on nous dit pas toute
la vérité
écoutez on est obligé de se poser un
certain nombre de questions c'est vrai
parce que là la gestion de cette crise
et est catastrophique depuis le début
alors c'est toujours facile en fait de
se donner l'impression en france qu'on
est les plus mauvais élèves
donc il faut quand même passer du temps
sur l'étude des autres cas bon si on
doit faire aujourd'hui un un championnat
du monde de l'efficacité mais c'est
clair que l'asie vient très très très
très largement en tête
non seulement parce qu'elles étaient
prêtes avant même que ce virus arrive du
fait de l'expérience qu'elle a vécue
avec le saas etc
dans les années précédentes mais surtout
elle a prouvé très tôt que ce virus
n'était pas mortelle à partir du moment
où on était préparé quand vous prenez
une ville comme hong kong vous avez
pratiquement sept mille habitants
kilomètres carrés et 157 morts en neuf
mois donc la première chose
effectivement c'est que il ya des gens
qui étaient prêt il ya des gens qui
savent traiter le problème il ya des
gens qui savent s'y préparer et qui ont
des résultats exceptionnels donc ça veut
dire que déjà on nous a vendu à
l'origine une maladie mortelle qui fait
que tout le pays devait être fermé ses
frontières fermées ces entreprises
dépecer et continuer le combat
aujourd'hui sans aucune raison valable
puisque c'est la désorganisation qui tue
c'est pas la maladie la maladie
malheureusement elle achève et elle tue
des personnes qui sont atteintes de
comorbidité qui a neuf dans neuf cas sur
dix ont plus de 75 euros
84 ans est malheureusement qui
accélèrent leur lors des ses banques
la deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
la logistique sur l'approvisionnement
des masques a été une catastrophe voir
un semis scandale je pense qu'on peut
aller jusqu'au terme de ce scandale est
aujourd'hui le rouge est la même chose
là on n'est pas très loin de nos voisins
néanmoins il avant il avance beaucoup
plus vite
et là aussi il faut prendre les cas qui
marche quand vous êtes préparés à
l'avancé comme l'a fait israël vous
fonctionnez avec un million de vaccinés
en quoi en moins de quinze jours trois
semaines
alors qu'aujourd'hui en france on est
toujours à la traîne et que nos voisins
vont beaucoup plus vite les états unis
qu'on a pointé énormément du doigt sont
déjà à plus de deux millions de
personnes vaccinées pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont préparés extrêmement tôt sur
l'approvisionnement ils ont 6 ans sur
est d'un certain nombre de doses et là
où je rejoins monsieur division alors
moi je suis pas scientifique je suis un
pauvre entrepreneurs qui se posent des
questions c'est qu'effectivement j'ai
toujours un doute très fort qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la chine ne
veut pas vaccinés la suisse ne veut pas
vaccinés la suède attend il ya un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde qui
disent 1
il ya tellement de variants qu'on n'est
pas sûr que le vaccin pourra les traités
donc pourquoi se précipiter sur celui là
deuxièmement on n'a aucun recul sur ce
vaccin développé à toute vitesse
ça serait quand même bien d'en connaître
un petit peu les effets secondaires de
façon non comment se donnent chaque et
pardonnez-moi avoir du recul injustement
hier d'ailleurs
les études ont affirmé que cinq
personnes sondées fabrice division je
sais que vous ronchonner mai mais voilà
il ya eu des premiers retours tout même
avec d'ailleurs 5 des bronches ou de
pommes adobe veut dire je ronchonne pas
c'est pas ça le problème
je ronchonne poche pas là pour
ronchonner mais à un moment donné on
parle de vérité transparence regardez ce
que dit la has regarder effectivement ce
que dit le parlement lui-même ces
vaccins
l'efficacité de ces vaccins sur les plus
de 75 ans n'a pas été prouvée et
démontrer vous imaginez bien
qu'effectivement on est dans un essai
clinique géant alors moi je dis pas
qu'il faut pas vacciner j'en sais rien
ce que je dis effectivement c'est que
concrètement à un moment donné il va
bien falloir le dire quand même aux gens
que cette efficacité n'a pas été
démontrée et que si elle n'est pas
démontrée ça veut dire quoi
c'est que j'espère qu'on a un plan b
quand même j'espère qu'effectivement on
entraîne tout misé sur les vaccins et
tout le monde s'excite sur le rex 1 mais
imaginez un instant que dans un mois ou
dans 1 mois et demi on découvre que 1
la variante sud africaine est telle que
le vaccin ne marche sur personne ou pas
grand monde ou que deux effectivement le
vaccin soit des personnes âgées qui sont
les plus fragiles et ne fait réellement
pas la preuve de son efficacité
on se croit à ce moment là jacques myard
je veux bien que vous critiquez la
vaccination de cette manière en dise on
n'a pas le recul nécessaire mais il n'en
demeure pas moins et axel kahn qui n'est
quand même pas un idiot et qui a une
certaine expérience médicale a affirmé
très nettement que ce vaccin avait quand
même une certaine efficacité et il faut
pas non plus exagérer
parce que je suis vous attendre à dire
ça monsieur
non monsieur messieurs s'est contredit
monsieur ce que vous dites est contredit
par l'autorité sanitaire monsieur axel
kahn dit ce qu'il veut mais je vous
invite à lire je vous invite à lire les
recommandations nationales instant vous
affirmer le droit d'écouter il s'agit de
lire et non monsieur je n'affirme rien
je lis monsieur août affirmé 30 c'est
vous qui affirmez moi je n'affirme rien
n'est sûr je n'affirme rien n'allait je
relaie ce que disait le professeur axel
kahn qui a très clairement dit que ce
vaccin moi je relève ce que dit la chef
monsieur vous permettez un instant vous
êtes peut-être avocat mais le propre de
l'art 4 écoutez donc ce qui est certain
et les propos du maire effectivement
monsieur c'est de rester l'année
monsieur si vous
claire l'émission tout seul vous la fête
mais sans moi ça commence à bien faire
donc il est évident il est évident que
sur ce point précis il est exact qu'on
n'a pas un recul énorme mais il est non
moins exact que certains scientifiques
et pas des moines tel le professeur axel
kahn disent que ce vaccin est
effectivement efficace et que donc ce
que vous demandez on l'aura
effectivement dans un an il n'en demeure
pas mois que l'associu si vous avez le
droit de dire ce que vous voulez le
droit de dire ce que vous voulez mais
vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur la question
des vaccins et on adapte entrée est
libre
l'idée n'est pas de se mettre d'accord
c'est que monsieur je vous invite à
l'une des recommandations
je vous invite à le lire il ya
effectivement une fois bolliger je vous
invite à dimanche
je vous a lui aussi à écouter des
professeurs émérites qui exactement le
voulez bien sûr la question également
des matchs que vous connaissez bien
aussi fabrice di vizio à cause de la
multiplication des variants à la haute
autorité de santé a changé ses
recommandations le masque en tissu s'est
notamment terminer je vous invite à
regarder cet écran les français invités
à privilégier le match chirurgicale et a
laissé aux soignants le masque ffp2 qui
est d'ailleurs toujours aussi difficile
à porter alors qu'en allemagne en
bavière le masque ffp2 est obligatoire
depuis hier dans les commerces et
transports ça nous rappelle les débuts
d'ailleurs de cette pandémie quand on
disait que le match n'était pas
obligatoire pour les laisser les c'est
en tout cas c'est rare masques aux
soignants ça vous rappelle justement
cette affaire fabrice division cette
confusion autour des démarques moi ça
effectivement inspire deux choses
j'espère que dans un mois va pas nous
dire que le vaccin était finalement pas
utile parce que finalement on nous a
vendu des masques en tissu pendant neuf
mois en vous expliquant que c'était la
panacée que tout se valaient et que mon
dieu il fallait surtout pas
effectivement m 2 ffp2 et on l'a encore
dit aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parce que
vous comprenez bien c'est très difficile
à porter il faut pour remporter
mais quand même la has maintenant vous
explique que les masques anti fugue ça
vaut peut-être pas tant que ça les
masques chirurgicaux mais juste pour
target anglaise attention hein parce que
quand ça s'arrête au niveau de la manche
basta cissé haddad la manche ne marche
pas mais alors j'espère quand même
effectivement comme cette affaire qu'on
va pas découvrir dans un mois et demi
dans deux mois avec du retard que
fondamentalement le ffp2 et le masque le
plus protecteur parce que ça on sait qu
neuf mois les allemands eux ont bien
compris puisque vous parlez de la
bavière
mais l'allemagne se pose la question de
savoir si elle va pas le généraliser sur
tout le territoire et donc on assiste un
phénomène ou regarder un petit peu où on
en est on à une contamination qui
augmentent enfin car en dents de scie
mais qui donc apparemment augmente et on
se pose pas la question de savoir si le
seul élément qui est resté ouvert tout
du long que les transports et pas
contaminants on se pose pas la question
de savoir si peut-être dans les
transports les moyens de protection qui
sont adoptées ne sont pas les bons et
bat l'allemagne se pose la question est
sondhi répondre données jacquet
l'entrepreneur que vous êtes saluer
inspire quoi
maintenant on est en train de glisser
vers les ffp2 prudemment mais sûrement
alors qu'on sait que voilà le marché est
inondé de tous ces jolis masques chinois
qu'on a touché est et d'ailleurs les
foyers certainement par par dizaines
il ya aussi le loup évidemment l'aspect
du coup les ffp2 sont beaucoup plus
chers oui alors ils sont effectivement
un petit peu plus cher en tout cas le
nom entre le mas de base chirurgicale
est ce qu'on appelle le 2er etc
ffp de honda on a quelques centimes
d'écart leur heureusement ils sont
l'écart est beaucoup moins important
quand il ya une tension sur les marchés
au mois de mars ou d'avril où les prix
étaient complètement fou et et en plus
les uns totalement indisponible d'ankara
clairement on a quand même une
disponibilité aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement forte et d'ailleurs
heureusement de ce que le privé s'est
emparé du sujet parce que si on a
dû laisser notre approvisionnement à
l'état je vous laisse imaginer dans quel
état où seraient aujourd'hui côté
entrepreneur je peux juste effectivement
me continuer à me poser la question qu
est la suivante si quand on sait que
neuf bon d'abord comme le rappelait
monsieur division on a une contamination
forte et malgré cette contamination
forte
on a un plateau légèrement montant ou
descendant depuis la fin du mois
d'octobre
mais en gros qui varie assez peu donc
pas beaucoup plus d'hospitalisations l'a
toujours 2003 2004 2005
2500 personnes dans l'est dans les
salles de réanimation aujourd'hui un
taux de mortalité qui à part quelques
jours ne bouge pas trop et pourtant
l'économie est complètement fermée on
est en couvre feu à partir de 18h et on
commence déjà entendre la petite musique
de confinement la question que je pose
c'est à partir du moment où on a ce
plateau pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait
ouvre pas nos économies mais aujourd'hui
si on regarde toutes les études qui ont
été faites depuis les etats-unis depuis
l'europe
les deux seul continent qui vont en
pâtir très chèrement est très durement
c'est l'amérique du sud et l'europe les
etats-unis vont s'en sortir la chine a
déjà rattrapé son pib au mois de
décembre 2020 tout le retard qu'elle a
pris en 2021 déjà et rattraper ceux qui
vont rester à la traîne et le notamment
sur le nombre de faillites qui va être
colossal en france qui évalue et aux
doutes de celui de nos voisins européens
c'est le nôtre donc moi je pose la
question de je suis à nice en ce moment
pour un certain nombre de raisons j'aime
monaco à côté a nice on a le couvent
reçoit à 18 heures à monaco les
restaurants sont ouverts on a eu quatre
morts à monaco en neuf mois et tout est
fermé ici je vois pas pourquoi le virus
ne contaminerait peu comme pas dans les
restaurants à monaco et contaminerait à
nice donc je pense qu'on est en train de
tuer notre économie pour une raison qui
est pas la bonne les clubs de sport sont
fermés on sait qu'elle est fréquenté par
les 18 à 35 ans qui sont vraiment de
quelques 0 0 quelques pour cent des cas
donc moi je pense surtout aux dégâts
monstrueux aux hommes et aux femmes qui
vont perdre leur job le retrouverons
jamais les petits-moyens territoire qui
vont perdre leur entreprise et ne
reverront jamais se demanderont pourquoi
très rapidement jacques myard parce que
c'est vrai que vous étiez 3 et ça a pris
beaucoup de temps de parole oui le mode
un frein pour vous effectivement on peut
vraiment s'interroger
il est exact notamment le traumatisme
pour les étudiants va être très fort
pour les économies
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui vont
être en faillite c'est évident sur
l'histoire des masques moi même j'ai été
commandé des masques en tissu rappelle
que le masque il est aussi pour protéger
vous protéger les autres plus que vous
êtes protégé des autres puisque c'est
pour éviter que ça vous plaise ou pas
vous savez pas brise séparera pas quand
vous éviter de cracher à la gueule mais
monsieur vous raconter n'importe quoi le
problème c'est de vous raconter
n'importe quoi et les masses de monsieur
c le problème c'est que vous pressez pas
par affirmation qui sont des
affirmations fausses monsieur mais rien
de violent que le marque en tissu et le
dimanche on n'est pas bons mais un très
mauvais orateur donc ce que je tiens à
vous dire c'est que ce vote est
révélateur
le programme cieux on n'est pas à la
figure des autres les masques même en
tissu avait un certain intérêt
alors maintenant on nous dit que c'est
laid mais jamais eu de tv un masque en
tissu le tac mais il n'en demeure pas
moins
il n'en devra pas moins que les masses
au permis de d'arrêter un peu la
propagation mais où notre ami de nice a
raison c'est que on n'interdit pas le
véhicule de se transporter dans les rer
et le métro et que à partir de 18 heures
on reste chez soi et c'est là où
effectivement on peut s'interroger et le
comparatif avec monaco est assez évident
merci en tout cas à tous les trois pour
ce débat animé fabrice division jacques
myard et denis
jacquet en direct donc sur rt france
merci à vous il est quasiment 20h30
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur notre
antenne direction tout de suite les
états unis si on veut bien dernière
journée de donald trump à la maison
blanche au moment où son successeur joe
biden arrive à washington et se prépare
à prêter serment dans une amérique
fragilisé et inquiète un passage de
relais en l'absence du président sortant
et dans une capitale aux allures de camp
retranché on retrouve en direct sur
place notre envoyé spécial thomas bonnin
bonsoir
thomas bonjour pour vous puisque c'est
en pleine journée à washington
alors à moins de 24 heures du début de
la cérémonie de la tension est elle
toujours aussi palpable dans la capitale
fédérale
oui stéphanie alors il ya de la musique
derrière moi les notes de bob marley qui
contraste un petit peu avec le décor on
a autour de nous c'est à dire donc ces
immenses palissade qui ont été dressés
et puis ces camions militaires qui sont
déployés la ville continue de se
barricader ces dernières heures et la
garde nationale continue de se déployer
je vous parlait hier de l'examen par
l'administration militaire des profils
des quelques 25 mille soldats qui sont
mobilisés ici à washington et bien on a
appris à la mi journée que deux d'entre
eux ont été finalement écartée du
dispositif car les autorités leur ont
trouvé des liens avec ce qui est
présenté comme des milices d'extrême
droite il ne semble pas que les deux
hommes est prévue la moindre action
contre joe biden demain mais par
précaution ils ne participeront pas à
l'opération de maintien de l'ordre
demain alors ce mardi thomas marquait
aussi le tout dernier joue en tout cas
le jour entier et un plein de donald
trump ou pouvoir quel est le programme
du président sortant
[Musique]
alors selon l'agenda officiel de la
maison blanche donald trump travaille
depuis très tôt ce matin jusqu'à très
tard ce soir il va passer un certain
nombre de coups de fil
c'est une formule qu'on peut lire depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant sur le
site officiel de la maison blanche et
qui reste volontairement flou sur les
agissements du président des états unis
mais selon plusieurs médias américains
donald trump pourrait profiter de ces
dernières heures à la maison blanche
pour gracier un certain nombre de
personnes le nombre qui circulent ces
deux cents grâce présidentielle qui
pourrait être accordée ces prochaines
heures à des individus aux profils très
différents les médias américains parle
par exemple du rappeur lil wayne
impliqué dans une affaire de port
illégal d'armes à feu et qui pourrait
voir son affaire être effacée grâce à
donald trump que le rappeur avait
soutenu lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle très peu d'informations
pour le moment sur les autres noms qui
pourraient figurer dans cette liste mais
selon des sources citées par des médias
américains il est assez peu probable que
rudi giuliani
l'avocat de donald trump soit concerné
par une grâce présidentielle peu de
chance également en ce qui concerne
julian assange deux lanceurs d'alertés
australiens restent encore sous le coup
d'une demande d'extradition de la
justice américaine donald trump qui n'a
pas pris la parole ces dernières heures
mais en revanche sa femme melania trump
a elle publié un message d'adieu sur les
réseaux sociaux
je propose d'écouter un extrait mes
chers compatriotes
cela a été le plus grand honneur de ma
vie d'être la première dame des etats
unis
j'ai été inspiré par d'incroyables
américain à travers notre pays qui élève
nos communautés par leur gentillesse et
leur courage leur bonté et leurs grâces
aucun mot ne peut exprimer ma profonde
gratitude et le privilège de vous avoir
servi comme première dame à tous les
habitants de ce pays
vous serez dans mon coeur pour toujours
merci que dieu vous bénisse pas de la
sio et que dieu bénisse les états unis
d'amérique et thomas de son côté john
madden se concentre déjà vers les
premières mesures qu'il pourrait mettre
en place
lors de son arrivée à la maison blanche
oui on sent que la volonté de l'ancien
vice-président et de détricoter un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises par donald trump il ya déjà eu
une première opposition et hier soir
puisque donald trump a proclamé la fin
de l'interdiction de territoire pour les
voyageurs en provenance de l'union
européenne et du brésil mais quelques
instants plus tard la futur porte-parole
de la maison blanche a publiquement
affirmé que l'administration de bail
donald et au contraire renforcer les
mesures sanitaires et puis l'ancien
vice-président prévoit de signer un
certain nombre de décrets dès ses
premières heures au sein du bureau ovale
parmi ses premières décisions réintégrer
l'accord de paris sur le climat ou
encore mettre un terme aux moeurs
l'hymne ban mise en place par trump et
qui interdit l'entrée sur le territoire
américain aux ressortissants d'un
certain nombre de pays à majorité
musulmane
merci thomas abonnés et envoyait
évidemment derrière vous ces images en
direct de washington on retrouvera tout
au long de la soirée de demain
d'ailleurs émission spéciale consacrée à
cette investiture de joe biden
en l'absence de données et à la veille
de ce grand jour le président sortant
lui pourrait pour son dernier jour à la
maison blanche prononcé une série de
grâce de personnes poursuivies par la
justice américaine
si donald trump pouvez choisir de
gracier ses alliés des assaillants
contre le capitole ou encore lui même il
pourrait amnistier julian assange
cinq lauréats du prix nobel ont
d'ailleurs écrit une tribune pour
demander aux républicains de
blanchir le fondateur de wikileaks
lanceurs d'alerté actuellement
incarcérés en angleterre risques je vous
le rappelle cent soixante quinze années
de prison aux états unis pour avoir
dévoilé des milliers de documents
confidentiels de l'armée américaine
nous vous écrivons pour vous demander de
donner une empreinte déterminante à
votre héritage présidentielle en
graciant julian assange ou en arrêtant
son extradition assange s'est battu pour
la vérité et la justice
son travail avec wikileaks a été le
pionnier de la responsabilité dans les
médias et a révélé la corruption les
violations des libertés civiles aux
états unis et dans le monde est le
véritable coût de la guerre en offrant
une grâce pour mettre un terme aux
poursuites d'assange
on se souviendra de votre présidence
pour avoir sauvé les protections du
premier amendement pour tous les
américains et pour évoquer l'actualité
aux etats unis nous sommes avec didier
combo docteur en civilisation américaine
bonsoir didier combo merci d'être avec
brochettes sûreté france doit être un
peu va-t-il utiliser on en parlait à
l'instant tous ses pouvoirs avant la fin
de son mandat la journée encore longue
aux etats unis décalage horaire oblige
doit-on s'attendre à des annonces
fracassantes ces prochaines heures ou
écouter c'est difficile de dire ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il va faire un
usage de son pouvoir de grâce comme
comme tous les présidents l'ont fait
avant lui
c'est pour ce qui concerne le trump
c'était évidemment assez contesté que
comme le disait tout à l'heure
correspondant puisque on pense que c'est
grâce seront principalement pour ses
soutiens
et puis il ne faut pas oublier que si
l'accord d'aujourd'hui des grâces il y a
eu un assez grand nombre d'exécutions
capitales au niveau fédéral et y compris
l'exécution d'une femme dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler qui était
l'auteur d'un crime horrible mais qui
elle n'a pas été graciées des décisions
aussi peut-être didier combo qui peuvent
gêner joe biden on pense notamment à
cuba qui a été remise sur les listes des
dvd aux terroristes par exemple
y at il d'autres décisions de ce type à
destination justement de joe biden enfin
ces décisions elles sont elles ne
peuvent être que symbolique puisque 1
prennent la forme de décret présidentiel
et que rien n'est plus facile ou
président qui arrive que deux
que de prendre un décret présidentiel
contraire c'est beaucoup moins difficile
que de remettre en question une loi par
exemple et et il est certain que que joe
biden ne se privera pas de le faire il a
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il reviendrait
sur le muslim khan se ce décret qui
interdit à certains ressortissants de
certains pays musulmans d'entrée sur le
territoire
il a annoncé qu'ils aient réintégré les
accords de paris donc ce que peut faire
un train à ce stade demeure un petit peu
de l'ordre du symbolique alors donald
trump qui est de plus en plus isolé le
chef des républicains au sénat a dit ce
soir que donald trump avait provoqué je
cite la foule dans les enseignants du
capitole qu'il avait abreuvé de
mensonges
qu'est ce que ça dit cette déclaration
du chef républicain au sénat que le
procès en hippisme pourrait peut-être
aboutir
oui c'est possible il y a à la chambre
des représentants il y a dix
républicains qui ont voté pour son
impeachment alors attention dit
républicain sur un petit peu plus de 200
donc sa demeure si sa demeure est un
tout petit pourcentage
il faudrait au sénat qu'il y ait dix
sept républicains qui votent pour cette
mpix chemin sur l'ailé sur les cinquante
sénateurs républicains ce n'est pas
impossible mitch mcconnell qui est
effectivement l'ancien président du
sénat et ou leaders du sénat à effectif
c'est effectivement prononcé
pratiquement pour ceux là où elle
laissait entendre que ce serait possible
et c'est quelqu'un de très influent donc
donc ça n'est pas impossible qu'il y ait
des décisions mais n'est encore certain
c'est qu'ils sont l'avenir nous le dira
alors en tout cas c'est demain que
cette investiture va sonner le glas si
je puis dire pour donald trump quelle
est sa plus grande inquiétude à présent
au président sortant cette procédure d'
impeachment la justice de son pays
je pense que la lame plus grande
inquiétude alors je sais pas si c'est la
justice ou une pile semaine parce que la
jussie ça va surtout concerné ses
affaires privées 1 il a il faut pas
oublier que c'est un homme d'affaires
mais il ya une chose qui peut
véritablement d'inquiéter c'est que si
le sénat vote link de semaine tu es bien
ensuite il peut voter une deuxième
décision qui sera que trump il deviendra
inéligible et alors trump ne pourra pas
se présenter aux élections de 1024 il
aura beaucoup de mal à rebondir
politiquement
est-ce qu'il n'est pas déjà mort donald
trump en tout cas le tropisme est ce que
cette sortie justement avec ces
violences au capitole ne l'ont pas
définitivement rayé de la carte
politique selon vous je suis toujours
difficile de prédire l'avenir mais il
est certain que c'est une sortie qui
n'est pas glorieuse puisque cette cet
assaut sur le capitole les deux tiers
des américains le tiennent pour
responsables et c'est quelque chose qui
est absolument inacceptable aux états
unis parce que c'est l'exécutif qui s'en
prend aux législatifs ou qui fait
pression sur le législatif et puis c'est
une remise en cause de la démocratie
donc c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement est désastreux pour
l'image de donald trump
mais attention il ya quand même une
petite minorité des américains qui
continuent de soutenir qui conduisent
soutenir ça parmi les républicains 18 %
soutiennent les s'est insurgé du capital
donc le trump ne peut disparaître
mais qu'en sera-t-il du tropisme qu'en
sera-t-il ce mouvement social qui l'a
porté au pouvoir
il sait ce qui sait ce que l'avenir nous
dira alors pour joe biden en tout cas
les choses deviennent
sérieuse il ne saura plus l'opposant
mais le président aux affaires
à quoi doit-on s'attendre les premières
semaines les premiers mois alors la
majorité dont dispose haydn à la chambre
des représentants et au sénat est très
faible donc au point de vue législatif
ça va être malgré tout assez difficile
même s'il a une majorité les démocrates
ne vote pas forcément systématiquement
d'un bloc est un des enjeux
ça va être le passage de la loi sur la
natte de la naturalisation d'un grand
nombre d'immigrants clandestins
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il veut mettre
rang route assez rapidement l'autre loi
qu'il voudra mettre en route c'est une
loi de soutien à l'économie à la suite
de la part des beats peu vide et donc il
y aura au moins ces deux textes qui
seront un grand enjeu au point de vue du
faso s'effacer ou sénat et à la chambre
des représentants avec malheureusement
comme dans tous les pays du monde un
boulet si j'ose dire à la jambe
l'épidémie de comines dont il s'est fait
une priorité avec des chiffres qui
flambe un des nombreux records de
contamination et de décès encore aux
états unis oui il suffit de lire entre
autres sur le l'inaction de donald trump
face au co vider son se sont peu
d'intérêt pour la question et les mêmes
sont c'est sa façon de nier l'importance
du virus sa façon de montrer comment
lui-même l'avait su remonter et donc
maintenant bailon il va est au pied du
mur parce que il va se trouver face à
cette épidémie qui ne semble pas faiblir
on entend parler de nouveaux variants la
difficulté de mettre en place la
vaccination est là on va le voir au pied
du mur et ça risque d'être d'être assez
compliqué justement à l'instant on
apprend que les états unis ont franchi
la barre des 400 mille morts liés au co
vie dans les chiffres ne parviennent de
l'université johns hopkins merci à vous
didier combo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur notre antenne et vous en
parlait justement à l'instant cet
antagonisme entre joe biden et donald
trump sur la gestion de la crise du coc
vide elle s'accentue même ces derniers
jours donald trump a annoncé lundi qu'il
comptait rouvrir les frontières à
certains ressorts qui sans une
déclaration vite démentie par les
équipes de son successeur guillemard
aussi une répétition de cérémonie sans
fausse note mais une véritable
cacophonie à la tête de l'état hier
donald trump a annoncé la réouverture
partielle des frontières le 26 janvier
prochain pour les voyageurs en
provenance de plusieurs pays
le secrétaire à la santé et aux services
sociaux m'a conseillé de supprimer les
restrictions applicables à l'espace
schengen au royaume uni à la république
d'irlande et à la république fédérative
du brésil
je conviens avec le secrétaire que cette
action est le meilleur moyen de
continuer à protéger les américains duke
au vide 19 tout en permettant aux
voyages de reprendre en toute sécurité
je juge par la présente que l'entrée
sans restriction aux états unis de
personnes qui ont été physiquement
présentes dans ces juridictions n'est
plus préjudiciable aux intérêts des
états unis
sauf que l'équipe de bayonne ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille
quelques minutes après la proclamation
présidentielle la futur porte-parole de
la maison blanche a contredit celui qui
est encore président pour 24 heures sur
la vie de notre équipe médicale
l'administration n'a pas l'intention de
lever ces restrictions le 26 janvier
en fait nous prévoyons de renforcer les
mesures de santé publique autour des
voyages internationaux afin d'atténuer
davantage la propagation du coc u19 avec
l'aggravation de la pandémie et
l'émergence de variantes plus
contagieuse dans le monde
ce n'est pas le moment de lever les
restrictions sur les voyages
internationaux
un épisode qui reflète les positions
opposées des deux présidents sur la
crise sanitaire
donald trump à relativiser à plusieurs
reprises la gravité de la pandémie et ne
s'est pas privé de meeting pendant la
campagne alors que joe biden a d'ores et
déjà annoncé le renforcement des
protocoles sanitaires et l'obligation du
port du masque la décision de donald
trump a d'ailleurs de quoi surprendre
la pandémie fait plus que jamais rage
aux états unis qui compte près de 400
mille morts et où le seuil des 4000
décès quotidiens a été franchi plusieurs
fois ces derniers jours et les pays
visés par la levée de l'interdiction de
voyager aux états unis sont loin d'être
épargnés sans compter le variant
britannique qui se répand un peu partout
et a été détectée sur le sol américain
il y a trois semaines dans le colorado
façon de rappeler que le coc vide 19
sous toutes ses formes ne connaît pas de
frontières et notre reporter sur place
nous en parlait tout à l'heure la
capitale américaine qui a des allures de
camp retranché aux états unis à
washington
à 24 heures de la passation de pouvoir
la maison blanche la capitale de l'état
de virginie accueille elle une
manifestation pro armes à des groupes de
diverses mouvances politiques se
réunissent chaque année à l'occasion du
lobby des une journée qui prend une
autre signification dans un contexte
actuel particulier guillemard au ski
cagoule gilet pare-balles et fusils
d'assaut dans les rues de richmond en
virginie
des images qui interpelle alors que joe
biden doit prendre ce mercredi la
présidence d'un pays plus que jamais
divisée mais pas de tentative de coup
d'état ici simplement un lobby des une
journée annuelle de mobilisation en
l'occurrence deux militants américains
pro armes
ces manifestants armés jusqu'aux dents
comme les y autorise la loi locale sont
venus devant le capitole de virginie
pour défendre le deuxième amendement
c'est à dire le droit de former des
milices et de détenir une arme et comme
de coutume au pays de l'oncle sam droit
de s'armer rime souvent avec liberté le
deuxième amendement est très important
pour moi je pense que c'est parce qu'ils
protègent les libertés il protège mes
droits il protège ma famille et tous
ceux qui me tiennent à coeur
je considère que si vous supprimez nos
premiers et deuxièmes droit d'amendement
cela signifie à peu près que nous
perdrons notre liberté nous devrions
pouvoir porter des armes
nous devrions pouvoir en posséder il ne
devrait y avoir aucune restriction à
notre encontre pour quelques raisons que
ce soit certaines lois qui nous cibler
nous empêche de posséder des armes à feu
ne devrait pas exister ou être licite
nous sommes ici simplement pour soutenir
le deuxième amendement des milices
devant le siège d'une assemblée le
tableau est édifiant
suite aux événements du 6 janvier au
capitole à washington le parlement de
virginie est sous haute surveillance
comme dans les autres états du pays mais
si les messages antibes hayden sont
visibles en ce jour de lobby day la
défense du port dame prime sur la
couleur du vote
eh bien le deuxième amendement protège
le premier 1 c'est pourquoi nous sommes
tous ici vous voyez propose là bas vous
avez vu boogaloo runs ici aujourd'hui
vous voyez black panthers là bas vous
voyez blm 757
ils veulent tous gardé leurs armes aussi
nous sommes tous pacifique et militants
de tous bords qui défie librement armée
en pleine rue la veille de l'investiture
d'un président deux semaines après une
intrusion meurtrier
au capitole voilà tout le paradoxe de la
démocratie américaine et l'europe elle
attend de savoir quelle sera sa future
relation avec l'administration byden
après des relations commerciales
détériorées sous la présidence trump et
hier soir les ministres des finances
européens ont échangé longuement avec un
ancien conseiller économique de barack
obama et les européens espèrent un
réchauffement de leurs relations avec
les américains mais ils n'ont pas eu de
contacts directs pour l'instant avec
l'administration byden depuis novembre
et il a savent
l'union européenne attend beaucoup de sa
nouvelle relation avec les états unis
les décisions trump yen reste encore en
travers de la gorge le soutien aux
partisans d'un bric s'il dure ou encore
les tensions commerciales avec
l'allemagne aujourd'hui de domaine une
évitables devrait s'imposer comme une
préoccupation commune la lutte contre le
coronavirus et le changement climatique
joe biden qui a promis que les états
unis réintègrerait l'accord de paris sur
le climat
notre engagement commun est essentiel
dans un monde où les puissances
autoritaires cherchent à subvertir les
démocraties reste à savoir comment s'y
prendre pour éviter une mauvaise
communication
point positif les européens discuteront
à nouveau avec des interlocuteurs jugé
fiable
le futur secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken qui est francophone et avec eux
à paris dans sa jeunesse et le bras
droit de ben laden depuis près de 20 ans
by donne est un peu désorientés face à
la complexité européenne les américains
ont toujours l'impression que c'est très
lent avec l'union européenne
pour eux c'est plus simple d'appeler
londres ou paris ou berlin
plutôt que de s'adresser à l'union
européenne si bruxelles pourrait bien
être la première visite diplomatique du
futur président pas sûr que le lieu soit
sa priorité
les etats unis risquent bien être
accaparé pendant les prochaines années
par l'asie et notamment les ambitions
chinoises 60
mais à 24 heures de l'accession au
bureau ovale de joe biden des candidats
on rêve américain ont vu leurs espoirs
s'envoler
hier au guatemala une caravane de
migrants qui aspirent à des jours
meilleurs aux états unis a été stoppée
net par les autorités grâce d'aia un
rêve d'exil stoppée net
des milliers de migrants honduriens ont
été bloqués par les autorités alors
qu'il tentait de rejoindre la frontière
séparant le mexique des états unis nous
regardons le sacrifice que tous les
honduriens font avec leurs enfants parce
qu'il ya des parents qui sont avec leurs
enfants nous battons pour avancer mais
la police guatémaltèque ne laisse pas
rentrer ne faisons pas de mal nous nous
battons pas ce que nous ressentons le
besoin non pas de ces derniers temps
nous enlever c'est sans rien nous ne
voulons déranger personne
nous allons en paix c'est à coups de
matraque et de gaz lacrymogène que les
4000 migrants qui bloquaient depuis
vendredi un axe routier dans l'est du
pays ont été dispersés ils étaient près
de 9000 avoir quitté san pedro sula
deuxième ville du honduras après la
capitale tegucigalpa depuis octobre 2018
une douzaine d'autres caravanes de
migrants ont quitté le pays pour les
candidats à l'exil plusieurs raisons la
violence des gangs et des
narcotrafiquants la situation économique
ou encore le climat comme lors du
passage de deux puissants ouragans en
novembre dernier le tout aggravé par la
pandémie
les migrants dénonçant l'inaction du
gouvernement hondurien ces présidents
dépense beaucoup pour l'armement parce
qu'il ne donne pas à manger aux gens qui
en ont besoin au plus démunis ou encore
ceux qui subissent les inondations tout
cela à cause du président juan orlando
nous voudrions bien savoir combien de
millions il a donné pour nous maintenir
à l'écart mais toujours est il que nous
avons tout laissé au nom de jésus alors
que donald trump a décrété vendredi
l'état d'urgence à la frontière avec le
mexique
de nombreux dirigeants d'amérique latine
se mobilisent contre les entrées
illégales de leurs ressortissants
500 agents mexicains ont ainsi été
déployés dans les états frontaliers
nous faisons des propositions pour la
recherche d'un dialogue avec les
migrants au honduras et au guatemala
guatemala et celle afin qu'ils puissent
être pris en charge et les empêcher
d'entrer légalement dans un pays un flux
migratoires qui génère des tensions
entre le guatemala et le honduras
sous couvert de l'épidémie le président
guatémaltèque alejandro gamme ati a
autorisé le recours à la force par
décret de son côté le honduras s'est
plaint du traitement de ses
ressortissants par son voisin et réclame
une enquête sur les violences des
tensions naissantes malgré un objectif
commun respecter l'accord conclu avec
les etats unis le mexique et le salvador
le 11 janvier dernier pour contenir les
flux migratoires
lundi ce sont près de 1100 sont dus rien
qui ont été contraints de retourner dans
leur pays reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
campagne vaccinale française olivier
verront promet de la transparence sur
les vaccins et le nombre de doses à la
veille d'un nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire et puis nous parlerons
de la stratégie française est-elle trop
laxiste vis-à-vis de ses frontières
alors que le virus gagnent toujours du
terrain ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
tiacoh politique n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême de
la société
tous les deux mois de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être que ce qui
va rester c'est que les films qui seront
de plus en plus fait pour le cinéma et
pas sur les grands réseaux resteront des
objets artistiques godard qui disait
cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux de teddy
[Musique]
une bonne stratégie pour l'état de venir
en aide aux entreprises c'est en cas de
défaillance est ce que véritablement
l'état lève sa garantie et rembourse aux
banques
le problème de ces sociétés là il est il
est là depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps que renault ne gagne pas
d'argent en vendant des voitures quand
le marché se retire on s'aperçoit les
entreprises qui ont constitué des
réserves financières suffisantes et les
sociétés qui n'ont aucune réserve
financière et qui ont fait des dettes
considérables depuis depuis à peu près
une centaine d'années concrètement est
ce que l'état joue gros dans un système
qui serait un système normal ils
joueraient l'eau aujourd'hui vous avez
des banques centrales qui qui imprime
tant qu'elles peuvent donc que vous
soutenez artificiellement un système qui
est mort
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale est
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de kia et
de cet appel d'air justement où en
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
deuxième émission tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 19
janvier à la veille d'un nouveau conseil
de défense sanitaire olivier verront
promet la transparence sur les vaccins
sous le feu des critiques des élus qui
espéraient davantage de doses
le ministre de la santé va publier le
nom précis dont chaque centre dispose
face à la contagion du variant de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour un
contrôle renforcé des frontières lors
faut-il les faire mais la france est
elle trop laxiste dans ce domaine ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face
et pendant ce temps en israël on vaccine
à tour de bras une campagne sans
précédent avec déjà plus de 2 6 millions
de personnes au compteur c'est en
offrant ses données médicales à pfizer
que l'état hébreu a pu recevoir un stock
supplémentaire de vaccins partage de
données rapides qui permettra de
connaître les effets de cette
immunisation sur la population et
entrevoir peut-être une sortie de crise
et des campagnes vaccinales mener à des
rythmes différents en europe mais une
préoccupation commune
la flambée des cas et la contagiosité
des variants en allemagne tour de vis
attendu nguena merkel a rencontré cet
après midi les dirigeants des 16 états
régionaux
outre-manche plus de 2600 décès
enregistrés en 24 heures un nouveau
triste record pour le royaume uni
[Musique]
le jour d'après pour l'ouverture de la
vaccination plus de 75 ans et aux
personnes représentant des pathologies à
haut risque une nouvelle étape dans une
campagne qui fait débat plusieurs maires
élus font état d'une pénurie de doses et
de la part du gouvernement d'un manque
d'anticipation pour leurs 480 mille
personnes ont été vaccinées en france
objectif plus de 2 millions pour la fin
du mois de février
walid bennani le visage un peu plus
fermé que lundi olivier ferrand en
déplacement au sens de l' agence
régionale de santé en ile de france
pas de bonne nouvelle cette fois
annoncer aux français ils n'avaient pas
l'info marée rouge ce sont des gens qui
sont positifs et quite a confirmé aux
variants oui maintenant oui pour
certains oui a le temps d'apprécier le
taux d'attaqué les variants venue du
mozambique d'angleterre ou encore
d'afrique du sud inquiète le
gouvernement
le ministre de la santé venus pour
s'informer mais aussi faire taire toute
polémique lié au vaccin
nous n'avons pas à ce stade les 6
millions de vaccins nous sommes donc
dans un fonctionnement à flux tendu à
chaque fois que des vaccins nous sont
livrés toutes les semaines immédiatement
ils sont répartis dans les neuf centres
de vaccination dans l'ensemble du
territoire national et donc à mesure que
ces vaccins arrivent nous ouvrons des
créneaux de vaccination
terminez pas
plus de deux millions de français âgés
de 75 ans et plus ont pris rendez vous
selon les derniers chiffres du ministère
quatre autres millions de candidats sont
aussi éligibles
un chiffre important et sujet de
préoccupation pour les élus locaux
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas exactement le
nombre de vaccins qu'on aura et ça ce
n'est pas normal parce qu'il y a de plus
en plus de personnes qui ont le kovy 19
est de plus en plus de personnes qui
veulent se faire vacciner
il faut que ça suive l'état ne doit de
la transparence
les stocks sont gérés au compte gouttes
les programmations sont gérés trop
lentement
nous ne savons pas quand nous recevrons
plus de doses nous n'avons aucune
visibilité
les doses qui arrivent sont de 5 mille
doses par semaine et la seine saint
denis compte plus de 1 million de
personnes il semble qu'il y ait un
problème d'approvisionnement
le gouvernement ne répond pas aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
le gouvernement rassure qu aucun stock
n'est caché à l'échelle nationale et
prône l'équité et la transparence avec
l'annoncé en fin de semaine du nombre
précis de de ce que possèdent les 900
centres de vaccination du pays
nous sommes évidemment et vous le savez
comme les autres pays des pandas et du
nombre de doses qui nous sont livrés
bien entendu il faut dire la vérité
la vaccination c'est une opération de
masse qui concerne le monde entier
les capacités de production sont à bloc
et la france en profitera au même rythme
que les autres
le ministre informe que tout français
ayant essayé de prendre rendez vous sans
succès se verra rappelé en priorité par
les centres de vaccination une procédure
qui doit être également initié avant la
fin de semaine mais sans encore de date
précise alors comment organiser et
jauger la stratégie française comment
expliquer la pénurie de vaccins
l'absence de contrôles aux frontières
françaises pour les ressortissants
européens
on en parle tout de suite avec alexis
poulain c'est notre rubrique lenny tôt
[Musique]
bonsoir avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france la
stratégie de l'excitation française de
plus en plus décrié on l'entend longueur
de journée par notamment les élus et du
coup on tente au gouvernement est bien
de jouer la transparence
oui alors les élus qui sont très
mécontents que ce soit martine aubry
françois rebsamen dans toutes les
régions pas seulement les plus touchées
qui se demandent en fait où sont les
doses comment ça fonctionne on attend
toujours à cette stratégie vaccinale qui
coûterait pourtant si cher à l'état qui
paye des cabinets de conseil pour la
mettre en place
il faut saluer quand même le talent
sémantique d'olive et veyran ministre de
la santé un qui passe de gestion de
crise à flux tendu en expliquant que bah
il gère une pénurie comme il fait depuis
le mois de mars
il n'y avait pas de masque c'était
inutile il y avait les tests ça a été
aussi très long à mettre en place
il n'y a pas assez de vaccins et bien
c'est du flux tendu et tout ça est
génial ça s'organise façon start up
nation
dès que ça arrive on vous dit quand vous
pouvez vous faire vacciner parce que
prendre rendez vous aussi c'est un
parcours du combattant
certains qui voudraient se faire
vacciner biens sont obligés d'attendre
jusqu'au mois de mars
et puis cette question de la
transparence c'est un mot c'est un mot
clé mais qui ne veut rien dire puisque
finalement maintenant dans la
communication du gouvernement
il n'y a plus d'objectifs chiffrés et
datés
on ne dit pas on va vacciner deux
millions de français d'ici fin janvier
on dit on nous allons aller le plus vite
possible nous allons vacciner le plus de
france est possible avec les doses qui
arrivent au compte-gouttes pas au
compte-gouttes pardon en flux tendu et
tout ça c'est de passer une super
stratégie il faudrait les applaudir pour
cette impéritie de plus pour cette
impréparation
de plus alors c'est catastrophique à
l'échelle du pays mais c'est le cas
aussi dans les autres pays c'est vrai
qu'on manque de doses partout en europe
effectivement alexis parce qu'on voit
que tous les pays européens connaissent
plus ou moins la même difficulté
la faute à l'europe alors la faute à
l'europe et aux partenaires européens
france et allemagne notamment puisque il
a été décidé que tous les pays membres
de l'union européenne ferait une
commande groupée pour faire baisser les
prix pour avoir aussi organisés
l'égalité entre les pays européens et
que tout le monde finalement et
bénéficie de la même pénurie de vaccins
et à l'époque
qu'est ce qui a été fait et bien les
français comme les allemands ont voulu
dans le choix des candidats vaccins
privilégier les candidats nationaux
c'est-à-dire pour la france sanofi qui
avait un candidat vaccin qui a pris
beaucoup de retard pour l'allemagne
curve ac et et d'autre mais surtout que
rak il a aussi été un des vaccins les
plus commandés avec celui de sanofi par
l'union européenne
malheureusement les vaccins qui
finalement arrive le plus tôt à maturité
sont ceux de pfizer biotech et ce2
moderna et là il faut se dépêcher madame
von der leyen de la commission
européenne pousse l'autorité du
médicament européens à mettre sur le
marché ces vaccins à la fin de l'année
dernière seulement voilà on en a pas
commandé assez alors aux commandes de
nouveau des doses mais le problème c'est
que pfizer lorsqu'il a eu reçu les
commandes c'est le premier qui commande
qui est servi on est maintenant en queue
de peloton
et puis les capacités de production sur
ces contrats européens sur les vaccins
les députés européens ont pu consulter
un seul contrat solide curva qu'il est
biffé c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas
quels sont les lieux de production
quelles sont les dates de livraison des
doses et surtout quels sont les laits
les capacités juridiques en fait en cas
de troubles avec les vaccins
hélas quand qu'est ce qu'on apprend
pfizer ferme son usine en belgique à
puurs parce qu'elle doit augmenter les
capacités de production files heures sur
le sol européen ne peut produire qu
environ 200 millions de doses toutes
confondues
que ce soit du duduk au vide ou autre
chose et là elle n'a pas préparé la big
pharma le labo father n'a pas préparé de
le fait de pouvoir livrer davantage et
donc on doit attendre les livraisons au
compte gouttes et ça c'est partout
pareil
et rien n'a été fait pour contrer ça on
est totalement dépendant que ce soit
pour les vaccins mais aussi que ce soit
pour la production des masques la
production des médicaments la production
de matériel médical
la france est tout simplement incapable
de gérer une pénurie sanitaire parce
qu'elle n'a plus les moyens de
production en local et dd2 look de
localisation sont passés par là et le
mal est fait alors au delà alexis de la
campagne de vaccination en attend des
annonces mais pour quel résultat
c'est ce qu'on peut se demander parce
que on demande beaucoup d'efforts aux
français depuis le mois de mars
confinement re confinement couvre-feu
c'est du stop and go des secteurs
entiers qui sont maintenant sinistré des
entreprises qui commencent à mettre la
clé sous la porte en nombre et malgré le
couac il en coûte 1 malgré la politique
volontariste de dettes à outrance du
gouvernement certains n'en bénéficient
pas et on peut se demander à quoi ça
sert prenons même les masques
aujourd'hui on apprend que les masques
en tissu sont inefficaces pour les
variants sud africain ou britanniques ou
quoi que ce soit il va falloir passer à
des masques ffp2 alors que faire de tout
ce personnel de l'éducation nationale
équipés en masques en tissu déjà
difficile de respirer sous ces masques
là mais maintenant on leur dit
finalement il va peut-être falloir
changer de base alors non jean-michel
bancaire ne dis pas ça il confirme que
les masques sont efficaces mais les
mesures qui ont été choisis depuis le
début ont un impact extrêmement limitée
quant à la propagation de ce virus que
ce soit le confinement que ce soit les
couvre-feux les chiffres ne sont pas
extrêmement probant et il ya autant
d'études qui vont vous dire que ça
marche que d'études qui vont vous dire
que ça ne marche que très peu à la marge
parce que ce ne sont pas des mesures
sanitaires
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de mesures
sanitaires que ce soit les traitements
préventifs et ça commence à venir il ya
une tribune de médecins sur la vitamine
d notamment pour booster les défenses
immunitaires
mais aussi les traitements préventifs
qui ont été moqués parce qu'on essayait
de faire avec ce qu'on avait et y en a
plusieurs
et là on attend le vaccin comme la
solution miracle or que se passe-t-il si
on n'a pas assez de doses que se
passe-t-il si on ne vaccine que d'une
seule dose
et que se passe-t-il si le vaccin ne
marche pas pour les plus de 75 ans
particulièrement et si on a d'autres cas
comme ces cinq morts a nancy où les
enquêtes sont ouvertes mais où il ya
trop de réactions allergiques il ya trop
de choc qui a trop de danger le problème
du risque et et 2
avantage aujourd'hui des mesures n'a pas
été pris en compte et on a une
catastrophe psychologique une
catastrophe économique une catastrophe
sociale et notamment pour les plus
jeunes
et là le gouvernement sont totalement
désemparés et ne prévoit pas de plan à
part prier pour une hypothétique relance
économique rapidement dernière
interrogation alexis la france doit-elle
fermer ses frontières aux ressortissants
européens ou au moins leur imposer un
test pcr négatif en arrivant sur notre
sol mais ce serait la moindre des choses
je crois que si on veut éviter la
circulation du virus
on évite tout simplement la circulation
des humains porteurs du virus
et qu'est ce que fait la france par pur
aveuglement idéologique seller en même
temps eh bien on empêche les françaises
sortir de chez eux à 18 heures mais on
accueille à bras ouverts tous les
porteurs de virus du monde entier dans
les aéroports avec soi disant des
protocoles mais qui sont très peu
puisqu'il s'agit d'une déclaration sur
l'honneur de dire qu'on va s'auto
confiné et qu'on va faire une
quarantaine mais ça ne compte pas et à
côté de ça vous avez des voisins
européens qui eux ont fermé les
frontières qui décide d'être beaucoup
plus moins laxiste et nous français et
bien on laisse entrer tout le monde
quasiment sous prétexte d'avoir un des
protocoles mais c'est pas le cas et
résultats et bien chaque pays européen
est en décalage et une fois c'est
l'allemagne il faut c'est la france une
fois c'est l'italie une fois c'est
l'espagne et le virus continue de
circuler sur le continent comme si rien
n'y faisait
donc à un moment il va peut-être falloir
se concerter au niveau européen pour que
tout le monde ferme les frontières en
même temps elle a même politique
sanitaire en même temps et de dire si on
est sérieux
un tant soit peu et si on veut confiner
les français comme s'il semblerait que
ce soit le cas au mois de février alors
à ce moment-là on ferme tout les
frontières notamment mais qu'on arrête
d'empêcher les français de sortir de
chez eux à 18 heures et c'est sa soeur
en même temps ça ne marche pas en règle
sanitaire
et puis le risque c'est aussi que cette
gestion complètement foutraque de la
crise est bien va coûter l'élection
présidentielle pourrait mener le
maquereau et on sent bien cette terreur
du politique aujourd'hui qui se dit mon
dieu si je fait les mauvais choix alors
c'en est fini pour moi sur la scène
politique non aujourd'hui il s'agit de
de manière sanitaire concertée et
réaliste c'est tout merci alexis poulin
et en parler a précisément de la
fermeture de ses frontières ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face dans
quelques instants
précisément le tourisme est frappé de
plein fouet par cette crise sanitaire
avec une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
martinique et la guadeloupe les
conditions d'entrée sur ces départements
d'outre-mer elles sont durcies depuis ce
lundi
objectif éviter la propagation des
nouveaux variants du coc vide et l'âme
et medjahed bienvenue en guadeloupe
la température actuelle est de 28 degrés
celsius la carte postale fait rêver mais
avec une certaine obligatoire et les
vacances prennent des airs de
confinement la durée moyenne d'un séjour
touristique en guadeloupe et de dix
jours alors de nombreux vacanciers
décide d'annuler leurs vols pour les
commerçants on est en train de tuer
l'économie de l'archipel
je suis inquiète parce que je pense
qu'on va rentrer dans le même scénario
que
l'année dernière trop tôt puisque
n'oublions pas qu aux antilles nous
sommes en haute saison
même si nous n'avions pas l'intention de
réaliser les chiffres de l'année elle
moisan il est évident que encore cette
situation qui a été prise samedi matin
pénalisera encore l'activité et c'est
une situation qui est catastrophique et
c'est pour nous le match je dirais est
encore un frein sur une activité qui
était déjà bien bienne handicap est déjà
très fragilisée par la pandémie l'an
dernier les opérateurs touristiques
espérait enfin pouvoir se refaire une
santé
ils craignent désormais de voir la
saison se terminer très vite alors
qu'elle a été lancé il ya à peine
quelques semaines la mesure d'isolement
de sept jours est entrée en vigueur ce
lundi
certains touristes sont passés entre les
filets à temps nous marchons sont
arrivés samedi
donc on l'a évité d'un pain c'est
chouette
oui je comprend pas du tout pourquoi il
mettre ça en place ici
les livres beaucoup plus livre même au
niveau du port du masque irait se sont
ouverts il ya pas de couvre-feu et les
gens font très attention quand même
la situation n'est pas du tout anxieux
gêne et on dit beaucoup mieux ici que
qu'en france c'est l'incompréhension du
côté des commerçants et des touristes
mais pour certains professionnels de
santé
les autorités locales ont pris les
bonnes décisions certains mesure est
déjà en application dans les îles
anglophones de la caraïbe et leur a
permis jusqu'à maintenant de ne pas
déborder
je pense que appliquer chez nous elle ne
devrait pas être une mauvaise solution
c'est vraiment le moyen de s'assurer que
ne circule pas les personnes qui
pourraient se positionner
après leur arrivée sur le territoire et
je crois que dans un territoire où les
capacités de plus en charge soins
critiques ne sont pas illimitées mais il
faut savoir anticiper ni de la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics de
décider devant le mesure tout à fait
adapté les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer sont parmi les destinations
qui intéressent le plus les français
cette année pour les vacances de février
la guadeloupe et la martinique se cale à
la deuxième et troisième place des
destinations les plus recherchées sur
expedia pour cette période
reste à savoir si les touristes
accepteront de passer sept jours sous
cloche pour retrouver un peu le plaisir
des voyages les tests pcr pour rentrer
en allemagne en italie renforcement des
restrictions en autriche les pays
européens s'adapte pour lutter contre la
pandémie en france de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent pour un contrôle renforcé les
détails avec robin pu l faut-il fermer
les frontières pour lutter contre le coc
ville 19
la question se pose une nouvelle fois
avec l' aggravation de l'épidémie au
cours des dernières semaines plusieurs
épidémiologistes membre du conseil
scientifique discute la nécessité d'un
durcissement des contrôles des mesures
coercitives voulue par certains membres
de la classe politique comme gérard
larcher ou marine le pen une fermeture
des frontières pas encore envisagée par
le gouvernement qui a annoncé la semaine
dernière un renforcement des contrôles
pour les voyageurs arrivant depuis les
pays extérieurs à l'union européenne
nous allons durcir fortement les
conditions dans
trait sur le territoire national et
renforcer les contrôles des contrôles
aux frontières à compter de lundi
tous les voyageurs qui souhaitent venir
en france en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne quels
qu'ils soient devront effectuer un test
avant de partir et il faudra présenter
un test négatif pour embarquer dans un
avion ou un bateau
de plus les personnes concernées devront
s'engager sur l'honneur à s'isoler
pendant sept jours
une fois arrivés en france puis à
refaire un deuxième test pcr à l'issue
l'europe tente de garder la main sur la
question de la liberté de circulation au
sein même de l'espace schengen un texte
a été adopté le 13 octobre par la
commission européenne établissant des
critères communs pour restreindre les
déplacements
objectif éviter aux états membres d'
avancer en ordre dispersé comme cela
avait été le cas au printemps dernier la
question sera abordée jeudi au conseil
européen
l'objectif est d'abord une meilleure
coordination sur les mesures concernant
les frontières à court terme
la france poussera pour qu'il y est une
reconnaissance mutuelle des tests
antigénique par tous les états membres à
leurs frontières
quel que soit le modèle de test utilisé
l'irlande par exemple ne les reconnaît
pas à bruxelles l'heure est encore aux
discussions ailleurs dans le monde
plusieurs pays ont déjà décrété des
restrictions croissantes à leurs
frontières pour lutter contre les
différents variant du coronavirus est
difficile de circuler entre la métropole
et les dom tom et pourtant pour un
allemand ou en italien on l'aura compris
à l'instant c'est beaucoup plus simple
la france ne pose pas de conditions
strictes face à la contagiosité du
variant de nombreuses voix s'élèvent
pour un contrôle renforcé des frontières
alors faut-il les faire mais la france
est elle trop laxiste dans ce domaine
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
prêt pour en débattre nous sommes avec à
jean-jacques 15 ans brodsky médecin
hospitalier à l'hôpital bichat à ses
côtés avait du vent un député européen
rassemblement national bonsoir à tous
les deux messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france c'est donc
une petite curiosité du moment le test
pcr négatif qui n'est pas demander à
tout le monde on l'a vu dans ce sujet un
tout français qui arrive du royaume uni
doit se faire tester en revanche si vous
arrivez d'allemagne aucune obligation
est-ce qu'il faut clairement changé les
règles docteur et contrôler nos
frontières quand je dirais d'abord
qu'indépendamment du fait d'avoir été me
de ca la lutte a mis cela je suis
professeur de politique et d'économie ta
santé axé ses problèmes de nature plus
politique finalement que strictement
médicales sont dans quelque chose que
j'étudie depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années maintenant la question c'est de
contrôler avec efficacité et de sabres
et de se baser sur des faits véridiques
j'entends dire par les uns par les
autres et même par monsieur poulin qui
est passé sur votre antenne ya quelques
instants
beaucoup de faits qui ne sont pas exacts
comment pourrait-on avoir des attitudes
juste si les faits dont parle date où ne
sont pas exacts alors s'agissant des
frontières il ya effectivement des
manques dans le système actuellement mis
en oeuvre par exemple on sait que
l'irlande largement exposée à la
variante dite l'anglais et que les gens
peuvent venir d'irlande au motif qu'ils
font partie des stades européens alors
qu'on interdit à certaines îles
lointaines mais dont certains pays
asiatiques lointains dont le virus est
pratiquement absent donc ya là un
paradoxe de gestion et vouloir raisonner
par contre catégorie n'est pas sérieux
voire ne pas avoir un dispositif
effectif comme c'était le cas longtemps
à l'aéroport de roissy-charles-de-gaulle
par exemple qui soumettent à un test
dont on est résultat en quelques minutes
l'ensemble des personnes qui arrivent
quelle que soit la couleur de leur
passeport n'est pas très sérieux non
plus donc là encore on est prisonniers
et c'est dommage d'une forme de bureau
si alors que l'intention générale est
louable ce que vient de dire le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes de suborner est sérieux et
vérifiable
ce qui concerne les frontaliers par
exemple trois cent cinquante mille et
quelques frontaliers qui passe d'un côté
ou l'autre des frontières de la france
tous les jours on ne peut pas
raisonnablement y mettre fin et on ne
sait pas si ces gens ont croisé dans le
courant de leur journée d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière dont il faut
beaucoup de discernement
il faut réagir de manière sérieuse à
partir de faits sérieux et non pas de
céder à des tentations politiques ou
politiciennes que ce soit d'ailleurs du
côté de ceux qui prennent des décisions
que de ceux qui s'y opposent je les
renvoie à ses ébats blement deux ados à
cet égard hervé juvin la réponse puisque
je crois qu'on rassemblement national on
demande clairement de maîtriser
davantage les frontières avant de vous
faire réagir on va écouter marine le pen
regardons les frontières je demande dès
le mois de janvier de maîtrise et de
contrôler les frontières
or tous les pays du monde on contrôler
leurs frontières sauf la france
le docteur alan gross qui nous
appelaient à plus de discernement
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
je ne vais pas lui répondre parce que je
suis très largement d'accord avec lui
j'observe simplement avec un peu
d'amusement que ce mot de frontières qui
était devenu un mot à peu près tabou
dans le vocabulaire politique les
frontières c'est ce qui devait s'ouvrir
c'est ce qui devait s'abaisser
et c'est ce qu'ils devaient disparaître
entendait encore ursula von der leyen
jusqu'au mois de mars 2020 avoir un seul
mot d'ordre alors que la pandémie
commence à faire rage
laissons les frontières ouvertes le
drame que l'on a vécu c'est que quand on
laisse les frontières ouvertes
l'ultime frontière c'est la peau d'où
les masques
d'où la distanciation social d'où ces
séparations qui sont en train de
produire des phénomène d'isolement dont
je crains qu'il ne puisse être
dramatiques donc soyons réalistes si on
avait très vite fermer les frontières et
notamment stoppé tous les vols
internationaux venant de la chine
si l'on avait plutôt fermé les
frontières peut-être parce que l'on
aurait mieux maîtriser la propagation de
l'épidémie
aujourd'hui et je suis d'accord avec le
professeur à ce sujet faisons preuve de
discernement
nous avons en effet des continents ou
des régions du monde où il n'ya pas ou à
peu près pas de casque au vide et nous
avons ce que nous appelons des zones
rouges où la pandémie se répand
continuer à se répandre voir s'accélère
et évidemment qu'il faut des traitements
différenciés
ce que je peux constater simplement tant
que parlementaires européens ayant été
appelés à réaliser quelques voyages
depuis le déclenchement de la pandémie
c'est que la france est un des seuls
pays dans lesquels on rentre comme dans
un moulin
je prendrai un exemple très simple j'ai
eu l'occasion de participer à un voyage
pour le contrôle du référendum en russie
avion à minsk tests sanguins covit 19 ou
pas arriver à un hôtel à moscou deux
heures d'attentes avant d'être testé
d'être autorisée arrivé dans les
chambres le retour à paris s'est passé
avec une facilité merveilleuse
absolument aucun contrôle à roissy et
j'ai différentes informations qui me
pousse à penser que c'est toujours le
cas là manifestement et je partage ce
que disait le professeur faisons preuve
de discernement
mais rendre compte qu'à force de nier la
fonction des frontières
à force de nier le fait qu'il est utile
qui est un intérieur et un extérieur
on a tout simplement affaibli la france
et mis en danger les français c'est ce
que je redoute dans la situation
actuelle d'absence de contrôle parce que
je le répète j'ai des témoignages
extrêmement récent à cet égard on
continue venant de différents continents
de pays étrangers à rentrer dans la
danse comme dans un moulin
alors que nos voisins l'espagne l'italie
l'autriche et sert à contrôler l'entrée
sur leur territoire
je ne peux que le regretter c'est de
l'avis des français qu'il est en jeu
avant de vous les faire répondre docteur
rose qui je vais vous faire écouter à
nicolas dupont aignan qui pointe
justement ces incohérences parfois mal
vécue par lé français alors qu'on
enferme les français chez eux on les
entasse ans dans les transports et des
magasins avant 18 heures le gouvernement
ne fait rien pour contrôler l'arrivée
des variants par les pays européens non
à l'enfermement contre-productif contre
l'ong plutôt nos frontières que répond
le médecin vous êtes docteur alan gross
qui dans l'absolu on comprend ce que dit
monsieur jiva ou ce que dit monsieur
dupont-aignan la difficulté elle est que
la propagation du virus
elle se limite pas aux frontières et
pays
vous savez très bien qu'on a décidé que
jusqu'à date récente
quel département était en rouge tel
autre ne l'était pas or vous savez très
bien que dans la réalité du vécu des
français et bien les gens circuit d'un
département à l'autre parce qu'ils
habitent une commune limitrophe
dans un département qui était rouge
foncé le qui travaillait dans un top
département qui était le gel et 10
revers ou l' inverse c'est à dire que la
territorialité l'adaptation locale à la
disposition des autorités locales
les maires les présidents de conseils
généraux de départementaux voir les ars
c'est cette absence de finesse qui nous
nuit et des décisions qui paraissent
être prises année à une échelle qui
voudraient englobée dans une seule
réalité une grande diversité et je ne
parle pas de la france d'outre-mer et
j'entendais tout à l'heure sur votre
antenne une charmante demoiselle charbon
touristes dire c'est mieux ici qu'en
france elle ne le sait peut-être pas
mais la guadeloupe et la martinique
c est à ce jour la france a tant donné
moi docteur aujourd'hui si on souhaite
aller moi vous
moi aller voilà en martinique ou en
guadeloupe c'est plus compliqué
finalement que d'aller en allemagne 1
j'ai encore bien c'est pourquoi je dis
c'est que je ne parlais pas des
départements français de l'outre-mer
français
mais pour s'en tenir effectivement comme
la team de suva tout à l'heure encore
une fois là il s'agit pas de politique
politicienne sur lesquels on pourra
discuter longtemps mais ça n'est pas mon
propos
il s'agit de politique de santé que la
politique de santé
c'est ce que j'enseigne depuis eu
tellement longtemps que on s'en souvient
plus c'est une politique qui doit une
distance de la politique politicienne où
les enjeux de politique politicienne
doivent s'effacer devant des réalités
qui s'appelle la propagation des virus
d'épidémiologie le fait qu'on a eu 6 156
morts en france aujourd'hui et 23 1608
nouveaux cas alors évidemment c'est un
tout petit peu moins mal que la veille
mais c'est encore terriblement
inquiétant est beaucoup trop
ici celle ci ne s'agissait que de
vieillards cacochymes porteurs de multi
pathologie pour après tout se dire oh
bah tout ça n'est normal on avance lors
d'essais que quelques semaines c'est de
moins en moins vrai et les séquelles de
l'infection par le coronavirus sont au
moins aussi redoutable que la maladie
elle-même et affecte des gens qui on va
de 50 35 ans 45 ans dans une
indifférence d'ailleurs quasi générale
donc le vrai problème est d'avoir une
vraie politique de santé quand la
politique de santé trouve l'écho chez
les politiques tout court ce qui
s'occupe de nous représenter au niveau
français ou européens alors tant mieux
ce que je dis c'est que là il faut
partir de faits très précis de
connaissance précise et qui ne sont pas
soumises à cette espèce de dialogue un
vraisemblable c'est la seule source
d'ailleurs que j'ai trouvé vraisemblable
dans ce cas dit le monsieur poulet en
tout à l'heure qu'ils manipulaient des
données exactes mais qui avait au moins
ceci est parfaitement exact
le débat entre scientifiques n'a pas à
se tenir sur la place publique ni même
sur les antennes de rtt les visions mais
là c'est derrière mon semblable ou
d'ailleurs mais on n'est pas les seuls à
faire des débats sur ce thème
je vous invite à regarder les autres
voilà le débat scientifique pour les
débats techniques avec des arguments qui
sont d'ailleurs absolument inaudible par
l'opinion qui n a droit de savoir la
conclusion que l'unanimité des
scientifiques peut en tirer
nous avons des autorités qui sont
embêtantes il tire des conclusions qui
globalement ne sont pas critiquable
ensuite il appartient aux politiques de
les discuter de les mettre en oeuvre
dans retenir ce qui leur semble
compatible acquisition économiques
sociales etc
d'autres arrières pensées qui ne regarde
pas les scientifiques que nous sommes
mais au moins faut-il partir de faits
véritables en tout cas c'est bon ça
convient certainement par le démon
arrive déjà à la fin de ce débat c'est
pour ça aussi qu'on vous invitez vous
avez pu exprimer votre opinion hervé
juvin la sienne merci à vous dr merci à
hervé juvin également d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france il est
21h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
cette antenne à la veille d'un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire olivier
verront promet en tout cas la
transparence sur les vaccins sous le feu
des critiques des élus qui espéraient
davantage de doses le ministre de la
santé va publier le nombre précis dont
chaque centre dispose
face à la contre josi tu es de ceux
virus notamment voilà donc pour les
vétérans et outre-rhin on se prépare
aussi à un prolongement et un
durcissement des mesures pour endiguer
le virus la chancelière allemande angela
merkel a rencontré cet après midi les
dirigeants des 16 états régionaux une
concertation avancé en raison des
chiffres inquiétants et de la
contagiosité des variants et ce en dépit
des écoles et commerces il en est
essentielle fermé depuis un mois la
campagne vaccinale est critiquée pour sa
lenteur avec 1,4 pour cent de la
population vaccinée à ce jour et
direction présents les montagnes
polonaises ou les patrons de restaurants
veulent faire entendre leur détresse
face au co bid les propriétaires des
établissements aux fraigne les règles et
pour cela il risque une amende qui
visiblement ne leur fait pas peur les
îles à saraf en pologne plusieurs hôtels
restaurants et bars annonce avoir ouvert
ce lundi malgré les restrictions pour
lutter contre le coc vide 19
ce mouvement de rébellion a commencé
dans les régions montagneuses du sud du
pays qui vivent principalement du
tourisme hivernal
c'est donc ici qu'a été lancé ces
derniers jours le veto des montagnards
après l'annnonce de la prolongation des
mesures sanitaires jusqu'à fin janvier
[Musique]
j'ai des informations provenant de
grands entrepreneurs les propriétaires
de chaînes hôtelières de stations de ski
et de piscines selon lesquelles d'ici ce
week-end ou même plutôt une grande
partie de leur activité sera ouverte
ouvrir ses portes malgré le confinement
partiel imposé par le gouvernement
les propriétaires des établissements
jouent gros la police et l'inspection
sanitaire peuvent à tout moment
intervenir et infliger des amendes de
trente mille sothys environ 6600 euros
nous contesterons cette amende en
justice en espérant qu'elle soit annulée
car elle n'est pas constitutionnelle la
constitution polonaise prévoit que
l'activité économique peut être
uniquement restreinte par une loi
or il n'ya pas de loi ni d'état
d'urgence ces entrepreneurs jugent le
soutien financier de l'état bien
insuffisant en quelques jours le slogan
on ouvre à fleury sur les réseaux
sociaux les établissements invitant les
clients à revenir
une carte interactive du pays a même été
créé pour recenser les lieux vote
décisif ce soir au sénat en italie ont
gelé venir du gouvernement de giuseppe
compte est contraint de trouver une
nouvelle majorité en pleine pandémie
coronavirus le chef du gouvernement
transalpin a obtenu hier la confiance de
la chambre des députés où les deux
piliers de sa coalition le parti
démocrate de centre gauche et le
mouvement en 5 étoiles dispose de la
majorité reste maintenant je sais
présenté à la chambre haute où il lui
manque sur le papier une quinzaine de
voix pour atteindre la majorité absolue
c'est une crise qui a ouvert une
blessure profonde à l'intérieur du
gouvernement des forces de la majorité
mais elle a provoqué aussi un malaise
dans le pays
c'est une triste qui risque aussi de
produire des dégâts à notre image elle a
attiré l'attention des médias
internationaux des représentations
diplomatiques étrangères
arrivé à ce point on ne peut pas effacer
ce qui s'est passé ou pensez pouvoir
récupérer un climat de confiance
il faut tourner la page ce pays mérite
un gouvernement uni qui se consacre à
temps plein a travaillé exclusivement
pour le bien-être de ses citoyens pour
favoriser une rapide reprise autre vie
sociale et une forte relance de notre
après une quatrième nuit de tension la
tunisie est toujours secoué par de
violentes manifestations malgré
l'arrestation hier de 600 personnes
les tunisiens sont encore nombreux dans
les rues en ce moment même des
protestations qui font suite à la mise
en place d'un nouveau en filmant alors
que le pays traverse une crise
économique et politique majeure la
correspondance à tunis 110 s'attendre ce
soir une cinquième nuit de tension ici à
tunis et puis sur l'ensemble du
territoire tunisien les tensions elles
qui vont commencer il ya maintenant cinq
jours le jour du confinement générale
annoncée par le gouvernement un jour qui
tombait avec la célébration du dixième
anniversaire de la révolution qui visait
une célébration de réclusion ont été
privés c'était la compréhension la
raison pour laquelle des tensions ont
commencé à surgir et ce n'était pas
simplement ce continent qui a créé ces
tensions mais simplement un confinement
qui est un petit peu mis de l'huile sur
le feu dans un contexte économique et
social assez compliquée depuis dix ans
les tunisiens ont fait le bilan de ses
dix années de révolution ils ont
l'impression que rien n'a été échangé
depuis dix ans ils ont gagné en en
termes de liberté d'expression mais
quand on parle avec eux hormis cette
liberté d'expression nouvellement
acquises rien n'a changé voire la
situation s'est empirée d'un point de
vue économique 15% de la population des
jeunes est au chômage et ça atteint une
30% d'entre eux dans d'autres zones des
tensions dit donc comme je vous ai tous
les soirs dans la banlieue de tunis mais
aussi dans d'autres villes de tunisie qu
des confrontations des violences avec la
police qui font usage de bombes
lacrymogènes
du mobilier urbain a été détruit des
magasins ont été pillés certains
bâtiments administratifs comme les
centres d'emploi ou été vandalisé les
centres d'emploi pourquoi c'est un
symbole pour cette genèse
or au chômage qui demande au
gouvernement de vraiment apprendre la
situation le président de la république
travaille sans il est même descendu dans
la rue c'était hier les entoure de 18h
dans la banlieue ouest de tunis là où
ils habitaient avant d'être président de
la république je vous propose d'écouter
si le présent la république à macha bape
tout
les jeunes tunisiens n'ont jamais été
des voleurs les gens veulent tant ployer
des jeunes qui aimerait servir d'attaqué
ou d'insulté personnes et non endommagé
pas les propriétés privées ou les
institutions de l'état les violences et
tensions assez palpable qu'on peut
ressentir sur l'ensemble du pays depuis
quelques jours qui ont conduit à de
nombreuses arrestations
avant-hier soir de 632 jeunes ont été
arrêtés de 14 à 25 ans c'est vraiment
cette population là qu'on voit en
première ligne tous les soirs à antrain
en train de confronter la police dans
les rues de la capitale et puis sur
l'ensemble du pays et ministres le porte
parole du ministre de l'intérieur a
déclaré que ces personnes-là arrêtés
devront comparaître devant la justice
il parlait une bien évidemment des
personnes majeures plusieurs appels à
manifester sont lancés tous les jours
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment
facebook et une manifestation doit être
organisé à partir de 15h aujourd'hui
dans la capitale
à tunis où de nombreuses personnes se
sont attendus bien sûr on reviendra vers
vous sur les prochaines éditions pour
vous en dire davantage cette
manifestation et cette tension palpable
de plus en plus ici on tunisie au yémen
les sanctions américaines contre les
outils classé terroriste par
l'administration trump entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui
hier pour protester contre cette
décision des manifestants se sont
dirigés vers l'ambassade américaine à
sanaa a fermé depuis 2015 en raison de
la situation sécuritaire imprévisible
des drapeaux américains et israéliens
ont été piétinées par la foule et les
affrontements se poursuivent dans la
région d'odessa autres forces pro
gouvernementales soutenues par l'amisom
lite et les émirats arabes unis par et
les outils soutenu par l'iran
des combats qui ont fait près de 150
morts selon des sources militaires et
médicales
cela n'était pas arrivé depuis l'entrée
en vigueur de la trêve négociée par
l'onu en décembre 2018
le 10 janvier dernier le secrétaire
d'état maxime péault avait annoncé la
décision de washington de désigner le
mouvement outils soutenu par l'iran
comme organisation terroriste étrangère
nous voulons que le monde comprenne que
l'amérique est le grand satan et le chef
du terrorisme
nous transmettons ce message au monde
devant cette ambassade que l'amérique a
créé le terrorisme
nous sommes sortis aujourd'hui pour
exprimer notre condamnation et notre
dénonciation de la décision du
secrétaire d'état américain de désigner
les outils comme organisation terroriste
l'administration américaine qui a pris
cette décision n'a aucune légitimité et
vit son dernier soupir
l'algérie a procédé à des manoeuvres
militaires dans la province frontalière
du sahara occidental et du maroc l
état-major algérien évoque l'instabilité
régionale pour justifier ces mouvements
militaires cet exercice de france
intervient dans un contexte de tension
dans le sahara occidental le maroc
revendique la souveraineté dans cette
zone
l'algérie elle soutient les
indépendantistes du front polisario
ces derniers ont affirmé ce mardi qu'il
était prêt à reprendre les négociations
avec l'onu mais pas question pour eux de
déposer les armes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
hassan alaoui directeur de la
publication
maroc diplomatique spécialiste des
affaires maghrébines bonsoir hassan
alaoui ravis de vous accueillir en
direct sur cette antenne alors pour bien
qu'on comprenne
quels sont les objectifs officiels mais
aussi officieux de ces exercices
d'ailleurs spectaculaire la part de
l'armée algérienne tout à fait vous avez
raison de spécifier les deux ternes lac
officielles et officieuses jovialité
c'est une rhétorique classique au régime
algérien je dirais plutôt à l'armée la
titulaire si vous voulez du pouvoir en
algérie et c'est lié à un contexte
particulier de ces derniers temps que
l'algérie est en train de vivre je me
permettrais de dire dramatiquement sans
jeter la pierre
ces convois qu' il ya un président la
république algérienne qui très malade
qui se fait soigner en allemagne et qui
n'est rentré que pour quelques jours en
algérie pour en fait entériner la loi de
finances et d'autres broutilles qui est
retourné dans en algérie vous avez un
mouvement de retour et de libération en
l'occurrence de l'ancien général à l'ena
qui était vraiment persona non grata
pendant un moment qui maintenant de
retour officiel plutôt officieux si vous
voulez on attend de voir et vous avez
aussi la libération d'un d'autres
généraux donc par tag médine qui étaient
tous des patrons du renseignement
algérien et en même temps vous avez un
climat délétère avec le mouvement en
irak qui ne qui n'arrêtent pas si vous
voulez vraiment donne une image d'une
algérie qui plutôt instable que en plus
de ça je dirais que la constitution qui
a été votée évidemment améliorée
notamment en son article pour permettre
à l'armée algérienne d'agir à
l'extérieur de ses frontières
ensuite la crise économique très très
aggravées avec une baisse
je ne dirais pas récurrentes mais
pandémique pardonnez moi l'expression
ses cadres de dire si vous voulez une
baisse du prix du pétrole
et tout cela si vous voulez ça donnait
un contexte mouvementé
en tout cas c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire très très très inquiétante et donc
cela arrive à un moment aussi où le
maroc n'est ce pas engrange c'est le cas
de le dire
des succès sur clos diplomatique et même
militaire puisque le 13 novembre dernier
l'armée marocaine est allé pacifiquement
je le souligne un sens en ce sens des
gammes sans rien mais en tout cas pour
évacuer si vous voulez le poids le point
d'ancrage s'ils voyaient entre la
mauritanie et le maroc où il ya un
passage important de véhicules de
commerce qui vont vers l'afrique qui
voulaient qui vient d'europe qui passe
par là le polisario avait décidé de le
bloquer pendant des semaines
mais le maroc a attendu patiemment puis
il a fini par se résoudre à cette
solution de l'évacuer sans anicroche
sans coup férir comme andy est donc la
voie est libre pour si vous voulez tous
les transports qui arrivent d'europe et
du nord pour aller jusqu'en afrique
et n'oubliez pas que le but de cette
histoire de gueule gilad s'est tout
simplement de couper le maroc de ses
racines africaines ce que l'algérie
n'est ce pas à s'est efforcé de faire
depuis
en vérité depuis 45 ans et que la
croissance a redonné moi parce qu'il
aime il ya plusieurs questions
évidemment ce genre d'événement il ya
toujours des symboles et l'armée
algérienne pour la première fois exhibé
un avion américain de reconnaissance
électronique
c'est le seul un armement non russes en
démonstration vous avez une idée de la
raison pour laquelle il atteint c'est un
avion qu'on appelle le draft 1909 ça
n'est ce pas il est connu le maroc
possède si vous voulez permettez détonne
je veux dire dans beaucoup de la viande
de ce genre en fait il faire quand ils
ne sont pas si vous voulez améliorer je
veux dire quand il ne comporte pas de
matériel sophistiqué place et a
posteriori
ils sont ils nous servent pour des
missions de voyage
personnel politique et militaire pour au
maroc donc cela si vous voulez
l'impression pas dit oh les forces
armées marocaines l'état l'état major
marocain parce que c'est à vous nous
avons l'habitude de les voir dans qu'il
représente systématiquement aucun danger
pour nous et donc ces faits uniquement
ce signal est donné pour que je veux
dire rassurer le peuple algérien comme
quoi l'armée algérienne n'a ne craint
rien elle est forte et armés tutti canti
et en ce moment on invoque un avocat
tort je considère en invoque l'histoire
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
les trafiquants de drogue et bien sûr la
nuit classiques historiques qui quitte
aussi un bouc émissaire c'est le baroque
alors on déménagera qui interviennent
dans un contexte tendu on le sait après
l'adhésion de la présidence américaine
un train au plan d'autonomie proposé par
le maroc sur le sahara est ce qu'on sait
si joe biden va renier ou non cette
décision prise par le président sortant
trump qui a reconnu
justement la marocanité du sahara si tu
es ma question récurrente et à laquelle
je veux dire sur laquelle se sont jetés
les médias algériens parce que tout ce
qui les intéresse de savoir si le
nouveau président américain joe biden va
ou non renier la position de son
prédécesseur la reconnaissance du sahara
marocain
et ben moi je pense que c'est une une
fausse question elle est d'autant plus
faux ce que de toute manière le bail
dance est un démocrate
alors qu'ils soient démocrates ou
républicains les relations entre le
maroc et les etats unis sont des
relations qui ont deux siècles et demi
depuis que en 1777 le maroc a été le
tout premier pays à reconnaître la jeune
république des états unis la jeune
république américaine parce qu'il y a eu
à un événement important c'est que
george washington avait demandé au roi
au sultan moi fils jean à l'époque
d'intercéder pour libérer des bateaux de
commerce américain qui mouille et dans
la mer méditerranée à gibraltar et qui
était attaqué systématiquement par les
ottomans les bateaux au tome est donc le
maroc hit et à intervenir à libérer les
américains et depuis c'est une relation
privilégiée
le marron qualité l'allié des etats-unis
pendant la première et la deuxième
guerre mondiale quand et si bien que on
a commencé à dire que le maroc site
l'allié des alliés parce que elite les
marocains les sauvegardes marocains sont
allés en italie sont allés à 1 re monte
cassino sont allés en france en
allemagne
ils ont combattu et même en indochine
donc il était l'alliée des alliés il
s'est justifié un petit peu si vous
voulez sa relation privilégiée avec les
américains qui lance qui ont intégré le
maroc dans le système de l'otan c'est un
site 1 c'est en fait je dirais
irréversible que personne ne changera si
bien que maintenant la question qui se
pose beit-el va-t-il renoncer il n'a pas
le temps maidana d'autres choix fâchent
à fouetter en l'occurrence il voulait
réconcilier les américains au lendemain
de faire réussir et de cohésion qui
devenu difficile parce que l'amérique
est partagé vous n'arrêtez pas par
toutes les télévisions de 10 et les
diviser aujourd'hui le premier devoir de
beit-el c'est justement de rétablir la
confiance et la cohésion sociale et
politique
les américains merci beaucoup hassan
alaoui jean paul ii un directeur de
publication de maromme diplomatique
spécialiste des affaires maghrébines
merci et d'avoir été en direct avec nos
sur rt france
et on reparle de la crise sanitaire avec
israël qui a été critiquée ces dernières
heures pour l'accord conclu avec le
laboratoire pfizer dans le cadre de sa
campagne de vaccination 14 millions de
doses ont été obtenues par l'état hébreu
contre un partage de données sur les
effets de la vaccination sur la
population
c'est ce que révèle le document qui
conclu l'accord un objectif que n'a
jamais caché le premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou pour lui ces données
pourront aider à développer des
stratégies pour vaincre le coronavirus
côte il s'agit de récolter et d'analyser
un maximum de données pour savoir à quel
moment une population vaccinée à grande
échelle atteint immunité collective
mais pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec ted avec un polar sniper sly
est un pardon de tel aviv pour arte
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir polar slayer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a beaucoup commentée par ce que il
serait le fait office de modèle de
premier de la classe partout dans le
monde pour avoir vacciné de 20% de sa
population alors des millions de doses
avant tout le monde et le ministère de
la santé qui a donné un début
d'explication avec cet échange si je
puis dire de donner comment réagit la
population israélienne
la plupart des israéliens sont en faveur
de la vaccination
les deux communautés qui pourrait-il
être opposé son et la communauté arabe
qui représentent 20% de la population du
rempart et les ultra orthodoxes a
commenté ultra religieuses qui sont
assez réticents
et ce sont ces deux communautés qui ont
le taux de contamination les plus élevés
mais la plupart des israéliens
soutiennent le programme de vaccination
et font confiance au gouvernement croit
que conformément à sa promesse est ici à
fin mars
tous les citoyens depuis deux saisons
ont été vaccinées cela fait d'israël le
premier pays à avoir vacciné la majorité
de sa population pour la sla ont parlé
de cet échange donné contre vaccin si
j'ose dire ça ne pose pas un problème de
respect de la vie privée
en israël personne ne trouve à redire
finalement sur cette question des
changes de données certains israéliens
ont fait part de leur inquiétude
effectivement en disant qu'il y avait
des questions étiquettes et violation de
la vie privée et dans le même temps cela
crée une division entre les pays riches
comme israël qui peuvent se permettre de
mettre en place un tel programme de
vaccination et des pays plus pauvres ou
aux revenus moyens
mais israël notamment le gouvernement
montre bien que s'agissant de vie privée
ce qui est partagé ce qui est échangé
n'est pas une information personnalisée
il s'agit d'informations en général tels
que par exemple nombre de personnes
vaccinées
le nombre de personnes décédées le
nombre de personnes qui ont contracté
une forme grave de la maladie
il étudie également la façon dont le
vaccin fonctionne il suivait l'évolution
de l'épidémie mais au cours du temps et
les différents taux de vaccination la
plupart des israéliens l'acceptent mais
bien sûr certaines personnes bien qu'il
s'agisse d'une minorité ont soulevé des
interrogations
alors justement pour la flyer
cet échange de données ça peut servir
comme vous l'avez bien expliqué avoir
une forme de retour sur expérience bien
utile un pour le reste de la planète
concernant l'efficacité de ce vaccin est
ce que on a déjà juste eu mans un retour
d'expérience sur les premiers vaccins
qui ont été injectés aux israéliens il
ya eu quelques informations je crois
aujourd'hui en ce sens sur l'efficacité
justement les autorités israéliennes ont
été surprise par la réaction suite au
premier vaccin
d'après les experts on ne s'attendait
pas à ce qu'une seule dose du vaccin
serait plus efficace c'est qu'elle ne
l'était il faut recevoir deux injections
pour être parfaitement protégé mais il
semblerait que les anticorps augmente de
6 à 12% après la seconde injection
il faut savoir que des milliers
d'israéliens sont tombés malades après
avoir reçu le vaccin mais seulement la
première injection et le nombre
d'anticorps n'était pas suffisant pour
lutter contre la coved après une seule
injection
ce qui explique la situation isralienne
sa particularité c'est que notre pays
est relativement coty la population
n'est que de 9 millions de personnes
israël a donc pu mobiliser tous ses
efforts tout sa recherche afin
d'immuniser une majorité du pays
le système de santé israélien a été
également numérisé donc les citoyens
recevait des informations par sms leur
disant de se rendre dans leur centre
médicaux locaux afin de se faire
vacciner
tout cela est numérisé et toutes les
informations sanitaires des israéliens
sont disponibles sous forme numérisée
depuis plusieurs décennies la
distribution du vaccin a été également
menées dernière logistica par l'armée ce
qui a aidé à au déploiement de ce
programme alors une baie
cision ce soir communiqués par le
gouvernement israélien qui a décidé de
prolonger jusqu'à fin janvier
les mesures de confinement et d'exiger
des tests négatifs kobe 19 pour entrer
dans le pays et ce malgré la vaccination
qu'est ce que ça dit finalement qui est
quand même une grande prudence sur
l'efficacité de cette vaccination que le
vaccin ne fait pas tout le gouvernement
effectivement est très prudent il s'agit
de notre troisième confinement en israël
et cela a commencé il ya une semaine et
demie et étaient censés se finir ce
vendredi que le gouvernement a déclaré
qu'il ne prolongerait pour dix jours
supplémentaires
on pense que le gouvernement ne pourrait
plus le prolonger au delà à car un quart
de la population a perdu son emploi
beaucoup de commerces sont fermés les
restaurants ne propose que des
livraisons
il y a beaucoup de colère concernant
cette fermeture de l'économie et
beaucoup d'inquiétudes quant à la
relance de cette économie
le gouvernement est très préoccupée par
le variant du coronavirus celui qui
vient à du riz mais également d'afrique
du sud
donc il faut effectivement avoir des
autorisations spéciales pour entrer en
israël
et ces personnes doivent se soumettre un
petit seulement de 10 à 15 ans des
hôtels d'isolation ont été mis en place
avec pour les étrangers donc il passe
deux semaines dans ses hôtels les
gouvernements ne risque rien il ya
également une dimension politique
au programme de vaccination en mars des
élections ont lieu et le premier
ministre israélien benjamin netanyahu
espère pouvoir
se servir de ce succès vaccinale est que
cela elle l'aidera à être réélu que cela
va renforcer sa popularité d'ici à deux
mois
merci beaucoup pour la flyer j'en ai
l'export rt internationale de nous avoir
explosé cette situation de la stratégie
vaccinale dans l'état hébreu
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'acte unique
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho politique n'a jamais tué